bon on
reprend ce que ce que je vous propose
alors
oui ça fait 30 minutes je sais mais il
était il était pas prévu que le temps
dure enfin la PPR dire aussi peu
longtemps je vous félicite pour votre
célérité par par ailleurs par ailleurs
comme par ailleurs comme on s'était dit
que la pprre elle est un peu durée je
voulais pas vous prendre de cours et
c'est pour ça qu'on a perdu certainement
un peu de temps pour la reprise mais
pour que tout le monde soit présent
ensuite vous voulez que les voix soient
mieux comptées alors les se rencomter ce
que je vous invite à faire pour que ce
soit plus compté je prendrai plus de
temps pour les votes vous levez la main
plus haut parce que comme cette salle
écrase voilà moi je vous vois très bien
j'ai aucun problème notamment ceux qui
sont devant je vois très bien ceux qui
sont derrière mais pour que chacun a un
décomte et bien on prendra plus de temps
pour faire le vote et comme ça ce sera
ne posera plus de
problème si tout le monde est prêt on
peut appeler l'amendement 177 de
Monsieur Lucas qui est défendu par
madameous merci monsieur le Président
c'est un amendement qui vise à supprimer
la double peine c'est-à-dire à à ne
pas renforcer les peines et qu'il y ait
une égalité de droit sur le territoire
français entre les personnes qui sont
françaises et les personnes qui sont
étrangères quelle que soit leur
situation administrative en fait ce sont
des justiciables comme les autres qui
doivent avoir les mêmes peines que les
autres et aggraver les peines de
certaines catégories de la population au
motif juste qu'ell serait étrangère et
un tentatoire au droit commun et au
principe même de la justice qui est que
elle doit passer pour chacun et chacune
de la même manière donc nous vous
proposons de supprimer cet article
monsieur Kerbrat oui bah dans la même
logique que ce qu' a pu défendre notre
collègue saint Rousseau nous souhaitons
contester la logique purement répressive
de la politique d'asile et d'immigration
que défend la majorité sénatoriale et
que nous retrouvons de la part de la
majorité gouvernementale
ici avec cet article 1 EB qui ADC les
qui durcit les conditions de délivrance
et de revendre un ti de séjour donc son
visé par ces restrictions les cartes de
séjour temporel et PU et annuel y
compris lorsqu que celle-ci a été
délivrée pour un motif familial
s'agissant du refus délivrange ou de
renouvellement se révisé trois cas de
Figur il pour être refusé de délivrer un
titre de séjour à un étranger ayant fait
l'objet d'uneocutf non exécuté par ce
dernier ayant commis des faits de fraud
documentaire etant commis des faits pour
lesquels les le retrait du titre
peut-être déjà prononcé je tiens à
préciser que 80 % des crimes des délits
commis par des étrangers en France sont
des délits commis de par leur situation
d'étranger c'est-à-dire en effet des
choses pour pouvoir permettre de de leur
survie et de pouvoir permettre leur
accès à un titre donc nous demandons
d'éviter toute euh répression
supplémentaire et nous demandons la
suppression de cette te monsieur vot oui
monsieur de la porte moiêmeou merci
monsieur le Président certaines des
dispositions prévues existent déjà dans
le droit en vigueur mais nous n'allons
pas hergoter c'est dommage le ministre
de l'intérieur n'est pas là mais c'est
lui-même qui a dit ça et donc il a pas
hergoté il a laissé cet article venir
notons néanmoins que ici quand on
demande quand on veut une carte de
séjour temporaire ne pas avoir commis de
fraude documentaire mais que on est
soimême en situation irrégulière et
queon doit faire preuve par exemple de
bulletins de salaire pour lesquels on a
pu fournir une fausse identité
c'est-à-dire que en fait on empêche 95 %
des travailleurs en situation
irrégulière de s'inscrire dans un
processus de régularisation donc voilà
là on est en train d'être face à une
forme d'absurdité totale du Sénat voilà
donc c'est pour cela qu'on vous demande
de la supprimer monsieur riman le
suivant fossillon le suivant oui
actuellement une personne qui demande la
délivrance ou le renouvellement d'un
titre de séjour peut déjà essuyer un
refus pour de très nombreuses raisons
les préfets ont généralement une très
grande marge d'appréciation des
conditions exigées et d'ailleurs le fait
d'être considéré comme menaçant euh pour
l'ordre public justifie déjà par
principe un refus de séjour or certainta
article il se fondent sur une
interprétation on va dire très extensive
de la notion d'ordre public j'ai
d'ailleurs pu le constater très
récemment dans dans les ces dans les
centres de rétention c'est-à-dire que en
réalité le trouble à l'ordre public il
va de la suspicion à l'ordre public à un
défaut de permis de conduire à de
l'apologie du terrorisme vous voyez
qu'on peut jauger les choses de manière
assez enfin avec je l'espère un peu de
de distinction euh et et donc là on
élargit de manière très importante
jusqu'à
rétablir la la double peine on pense y
compris que ok la suite après monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur
général non mais je suis étonné de du
terme double peine d'ailleurs tout le
monde ne l'a pas utilisé parce qu'il
n'est pas exact euh il n'y a pas de
dispositif de double peine de la même
façon Mame Rousseau que il ne s'agit pas
de retirer son titre ou de de renforcer
les peines des étrangers parce que il
serait étranger à aucun moment mais non
non n pas c'est pas dit pas si SICI non
c'est non en fait très clairement donc
voilà je veux
bien de quoi est-il question madame
Rousseau il est question de refus de
délivrance de refus de renouvellement
d'une carte de séjour temporaire ou
plurannuel sur des catégories
d'infraction pénale
existante sur décision motivée du préfet
ça s'appelle pas une double peine ça
s'appelle la décision motivée du préfet
qui peut nous aurons ce débat d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure certains veulent que ça
soit il doit non il peut il peut quand
un certain nombre d'infractions sont
constaté au terme de l'article 1er B du
Sénat il peut refuser la délivrance
refuser le renouvellement d'une carte de
séjour temporaire plus annuel ça n'est
pas la double peine la double peine ça
sera autre chose on le verra plus tard
dans le texte sur d'autres aspects mais
une fois que j'ai dit cela je ne suis
pour autant pas d'accord avec la
rédaction du Sénat telle qu'elle
apparaît parce que cela a été très bien
dit par Monsieur de laaporte tout à
l'heure cela a été très bien dit par
Monsieur de laaport tout à l'heure au
fond cet article pose un double problème
d'une part il vient recouper des
dispositions de l'article 13 et donc il
y a des chevauchements qui sont
incohérents disons-le et puis il vient
surtout rappeler des possibilités de
délivrance et de refus de renouvellement
qui existe déjà qui existe déjà et donc
Madame Rousseau le problème du Sénat ça
n'est pas qu'il crée une double peine ou
qui viendrait renforcer ou renforcer des
peines pour les étrangers parce qu'il
seraient étranger mais c'est simplement
que il vient compiler dans un seul
article des dispositions qui existent
déjà par ailleurs raison pour laquelle
j'ai essayé de faire un travail
relativement rationnel je vais vous
proposer un amendement dans quelques
minutes qui va d'une certaine façon
nettoyer l'article 1er B pour ne retenir
qu'un seul élément je vois que ça
intéresse absolument tout le monde
contte tenu du du niveau sonore de cette
salle je vous remercie vraiment pour
votre attention elle me touche très
profondément mais ce que je proposera
c'est que nous retenions comme
possibilité pour le préfet de ref de
refuser de délivrer ou de refuser de
renouveler des éléments qui n'existent
pas aujourd'hui et notamment sur les
atteintes aux élus sur les atteintes aux
élus et donc vous verrez tout à l'heure
cet amendement je crois que c'est le
suivant c'est le
1662 je recentre sur des éléments qui
sont légitimes ça n'est ni la double
peine ni le renfor cement des peines
pour les étrangers parce qu'il serit
étranger bien sûr donc défavorable au
suppression et puis bien sûr favorable à
l'aménagement très significatif que je
vous propose pour cet article 1er B
alors atint Monsieur di Filippo at merci
beaucoup monsieur le le Président je
suis assez estomaqué qu'on considère que
des personnes qui se sont maintenu
illégalement sur le territoire français
ou qui ont commis un certain nombre de
délits ou de crimes ont vocation à y
demeurer et puissent avoir des bonnes
perspectives d'intégration euh on peut
parler effectivement de de certains de
certains délits comme le faux l'usage de
faux l'extorsion et avoir une excuse
sociale comme vous l'avez eu euh en
considérant que que c'est la la
nécessité de subsistance mais on parle
aussi de trafic de stupéfiants de
réduction en esclavage d'une personne de
proxénétisme de traite des êtres des
êtres humains à un moment donné des
personnes qui demeurent en France qui ne
respectent pas les OQTF euh qui y
prospèrent par des trafics en tout genre
n'ont pas vocation à rester dans notre
pays elles ne s'y intégreront pas quand
on a bénéficié de l'accueil et de la
générosité de la France cela vaut au
moins qu'on en respecte un minimum les
lois monsieur
kirbrat bon il y a une logique derrière
tout ça hein
euh c'est Madame regol
après c'est la faute à Rousseau je
parlais à Madame Rousseau monsieur
cabrade continuer merci beaucoup euh
logique derrière tout
ça monsieur le Président a coupé mon
micro donc je disais une logique
derrière tout ça qui est cette logique
surrépressive que veut ce projet de loi
être méchant avec les méchants je pense
que mes collègues ont quand même dit ce
qu'il a étéin parce du risque double
peine et ainsi de suite je veux quand
même souligner le fait
que ce texte prévoit cet article prévoit
à la fois la possibilité de sanctionner
des délits end par donc l'application
potentielle d'un informement dans un
centre de rétention puis une expulsion
mais aussi de poursuite pénale qui
peut-être la prison donc la double peine
existe car en effet d'avoir une sanction
pénale de la prison puis ensuite d'une
expulsion ça s'appelle la double peine
ça s'appelle pas autrement et si ça
s'appelle la double peine je suis le
rapporteur tout de même à partir du
moment où il y a deux peines ça
s'appelle la double peine et l'excluion
est une peine mais surtout surtout vous
prévoyez dans ce texte la potentialité
de commettre un délit c'estàdire que ce
n'est même pas un texte qui se limite à
sanctionner un dél c'est un texte qui
présuppose madame
fossillon vous aviez dit que vous
vouliez rebondir mais c'est pas grave
alors madame rol vous avz dit aura un
deuxème tour
alorsper mais merci monsieur le
Président outre tous les arguments mis
en avant par mes collègues il y a celui
sur lequel intervenait au tout début mon
collègue de la porte qui est celui des
arguments même du ministre qui soulligne
le fait que par cette répétition cette
espèce de mille feuilles une espèce de
répétition pas tout à fait à l'identique
avec des petites variations ce qu'on
crée ce sont des failles dans nos textes
et donc la possibilité de jurisprudence
qui rendre inapplicable ce que nous
sommes en train de voter je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure je ne comprends pas
comment quand la loi prévoit déjà les
cas de figure quand les choses sont déjà
inscrite on a besoin de réécrire quelque
chose alors je comprends et c'est
dommage que monsieur le ministre ne soit
pas là pour nous R répondre je comprends
qu'il y ait des accords pour essayer
d'obtenir des votes mais peut-être que
notre travail de législateur et de
législatrice ici et de faire des textes
qui soient applicables qui soient
compréhensibles et qui ne laissent
aucune place à des mésinterprétations
c'est exactement ce que nous sommes en
train de faire et c'est extrêmement
dangereux et je le rappelle très
attacablead merci monsieur le Président
alors nous au groupe RN nous sommes
absolument médusés horrifiés stupéfaits
à la lecture de ces amendements de nos
collègues d'extrême gauche qui font
preuve d'une bienveillance inouie à
l'égard d'étranger mais pas n'importe
quels étrangers ceux qui sont en
situation d'infraction on parle ici de
fraude documentaire on parle ici de de
d'absence de respect d'obligation de
quitter le territoire français mais
cette mensuétude à l'égard des Français
qui violent notre loi et qui se
maintiennent et qui se maintien tienne
illégalement sur le territoire national
mais en fait qu'est-ce que vous cherchez
on a déjà le taux d'exécution d'qtf le
plus faible d'Europe ou quasiment le
plus faible d'Europe vous vous voulez
vraiment détenir les pires records en la
matière nous RN nous considérons que
quand vous êtes étranger et
généreusement accueilli sur le
territoire national vous devez bien vous
comporter vous devez respecter les lois
nous orn on ne légitimera jamais la
fraude et on nexcusera jamais la
violation de la loi alors sur le vote de
ces amendements de suppression qui vote
pour qui vote
contre
rejeté monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
la parole pour votre amendement 1662
oui juste un élément de réponse
notamment
à par rapport à l'intervention de
Monsieur Filippo de Philippo il y a
quelques instants on est bien d'accord
que les infractions pénales que vous
avez évoqué mon cher collègue le
proxénétisme la fraude documentaire le
trafic de stupéfiants toutes les
infractions que vous avez évoqué sont
déjà dans le droit existant des cas de
refus de délivrance d'un titre de séjour
ou de renouvellement je je je le signale
nous ne supprimons pas ces dispositions
simplement nous clarifions un article
qui les condensé inutilement et
l'amendement que je vous propose le 1662
consiste à resserrer la focale sur ce
qui est un défaut dans le droit existant
c'est tout ce qui concerne les atteintes
aux élus aux élus quel qu'il soi y
compris d'ailleurs les députés les
sénateurs donc voilà le sens de cet
article 1662 qui effectivement écrase
l'article 1er B sauf sur ses
dispositions monsieur
marcangelli je soutiens le l'amendement
selon je vais laisser la parole à à
Monsieur Pradal parce que je viens
d'arriver j'avais pas bienrangé mes
affaires pour tot ement honnête ça
arrive
voilà allez dans la minute restante
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
donc le groupe horizon et apparenté
soutient l'amendement du rapporteur
général de réécriture et souhaite
exprimer quand même que comme il écrase
les amendements 236 237 1238 et 1239 que
nous avions déposé sous par ces
amendements marquer une réflexion sur
une compétence liée du préfet sur le cas
des renouvellements ou autorisations sur
des infraction particulièrement grave
c'est un point qui qui nous paraissait
important et je souhaitais le signaler
au soutien de l'AM c'est 162 du
rapporteur général madame
Martin au moi ma question est fort
simple hein c'est combien y a-t-il de
situations où des élus enfin où il y a
eu des atteintes aux élus de la part
d'étrangers je trouve que ça serait
éclairant de la part de votre part
puisque vous ajoutez cet élément
monsieur Pouget
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur par votre nouvelle rédaction
vous allez faire tomber la plupart des
des amendements qui vont arriver parce
que vous cantonnez au au mandat électif
soit néanmoins je rappelle que le droit
actuel permet par le fait que le préfet
peut mais il n'est pas obligé n la
plupart des amendements que prévoyent un
certain nombre de collègues notamment
les collègues du groupe horizon donn une
impérativité à la décision et ça c'est
quelque chose d'important et la deuxième
chose moi j'avais proposé des
amendements qui intégra les étrangers
condamnés pour fait de
terrorisme ça me semble un sujet
important dans notre société aujourd'hui
et il me semble que lorsqu'un étranger
est condamné pour acte de terrorisme on
peut pas laisser le peu à disposition il
faut que ce soit il faut que la la la
décision soit impérative et fixée dans
la loi merci et enfin Madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
ouous il nous apparaît tout à fait
normal que quand un étranger commet des
faits de fraude documentaire de
production ou de fabrication illicite de
stupéfiants et de proxénétisme et bien
oui il doit y avoir une sanction et
l'étranger doit pouvoir se voir retirer
son titre de séjour nous nous
considérons que cette rédaction de
l'article ne va pas assez loin parce
qu'il ne faut il faut pas que ça soit
une possibilité de retrait du titre il
faut que ça soit une
automaticité en revanche le fait que
vous fassz un focus sur le statut de
l'élu nous semble tout à fait pertinent
quand on voit
que qu'un nombre important de Maes font
l'objet d'insulte d'incivilité voire
même de violence physique oui en effet
il faut protéger les élus je pense que
c'est une demande de leur part et ça
permettra peut-être de palier au nombre
considérable et en constante
augmentation de
démission alors s'il vous plaît j'ai
demandé votre attention une minute donc
je vais vous demandé de vous taire une
minute pour qu'on puisse passer au vote
j'appelle les gens qui votent pour
l'amendement du
rapporteur très bien j'appelle les gens
qui votent contre l'amendement du
rapporteur donc l'amendement du
rapporteur est adopté il fait tomber
tous les amendements puisquil rédige
l'article monsieur le rapporteur vous
pouvez surtout présenter votre
amendement suivant le
merci monsieur le
Président s'il vous plaît
franchement si vous pouve ça sera
vraiment bien juste écouter le
rapporteur qui un nouau un excellent
amendement pas simplement moi mais qu'on
s'écoute quoi tout simplement de façon
générale ça serait ça serait vachement
bien l'amendement 1663 qui porte sur
l'article 1er C c'est EC pardon c'est un
amendement de
suppression je voudrais expliquer pour
quelle
raison cette cette disposition proposée
par le Sénat propose
d'allonger la durée de séjour en France
de 3 ans à 5 ans pour bénéficier d'un
certain nombre de de de situations qui
sont par exemple l'accès au mariage qui
sont par
exemple la situation des parents
d'enfant nous estimons que cette durée
est excessive n'est pas proportionné au
regard de la durée actuelle de 3 ans
notamment pour accéder à la carte de
résident et nous estimons que les les
situations s'il vous plaît
franchement c'est insupportable même moi
j'entends pas le rapporteur donc
j'imagine pas vous même moi je ne
m'entend pas c'est c'est c'est pour
dire c'est pas simple voilà je crois que
vous avez compris le sens de mon
amendement et donc euh euh je vous
suggère par conséquent de l'adopter
l'amendement du rapporteur étant
excellent j'en ai déposé en identique et
donc je passe la parole ensuite à
Monsieur Lucas pour l'amendement 178
merci président très très rapidement B
cette cet article réussit l'exploit
évidemment bon dans dans dans ce texte
de s'en prendre aux étrangers en
situation euh régulière ou irrégulière
mais également aux françaises et aux
Français qui ont un conjoint une
conjointe venue d'un d'un autre PS nous
nous faisons ici l'écho comme vous de de
l'alerte et des préconisations de la
Défenseur des droits sur une restriction
inédite porté au droit des Français de
mener une vie familiale normale il y a
aucune raison valable de de passer de 3
à 5 ans ça crée par ailleurs une
insécurité juridique considérable et
donc nous proposons également
d'éviter une horreur de plus dans dans
ce texte et donc de supprimer cet
article 1emier EC euh madame torignia
suivant merci monsieur le Président bon
c'est la même chose nous on propose
aussi de supprimer cet article parce
qu'on voit pas qu'elleintérêt de
d'allonger la la durée du du mariage
pour obtenir ce ce titre par ailleurs
moi je veux encore rappeler que ça fait
plus de ça doit faire 8 ou 9h que nous
sommes sur l'examen de ce texte qu'en
fait nous n'avons pas vraiment entamé le
le le texte on est toujours sur ces
amendements qui ont été rajouté par le
Sénat et on ne parle que de répression
que de limitation de droit des étrangers
et quand les députés du rassemblement
national nous disent que les étrangers
qui ont été généreusement accueillis je
tiens à vous rappeler que depuis le
début que nous avons examiné ce texte
nous n'avons jamais encore parlé
d'accueil alors donc on est vraiment sur
sur des visions complètement
différente alors monsieur
ô madame Caraman alors oui monsieur le
Président comme les autres collègues
précédemment je tienais quand même à
insister particulièrement sur cet
argument présenté par le texte qui
consiste finalement encore rendre une
l'administration en tout cas une
précarité administrative au couple et
aussi donc au conjoint étrangers bien
sûr là vous vous voulez ajouter encore
des années donc passz maintenant de TR
an à 5 ans c'est c'est vraiment enfin je
n'ai pas de mot pour qualifier cette
cette mesure et je regrette aussi que le
ministre d'ailleurs quand il a il a en
présence lors du débat au Sénat n'a même
pas réagi il a laissé faire donc voilà
je je suis
moi-même conjointe finalement d'un
français bien sûr j'ai obtenu la
nationalité française par mariage et à
l'époque il n'y avait même pas
finalement une exigence de durée pour
pouvoir finalement acquérir la
nationalité donc voilà je trouve que
c'est ces façons de de durcir finalement
la situation des conjoints n'a pas de
sens n'a pas de de place dans ce texte
madame
fossillon merci monsieur le Président il
y a vraiment une obsession sur cette
question soit du regroupement familial
soit des des conjoints étrangers on y
passe quand même beaucoup de temps pour
12 à 14000 titres annuels euh on voit
que là très clairement il s'agit
d'entraver l'accès au au séjour et et et
précariser la situation des familles
francoétrangères avec disons-le en plus
un risque d'engorgement plus grand des
services préfectoraux d'ailleurs la
Défenseur des droits souligne qu'en plus
de l'impact financier que ces
modifications
emporteraient avec les taxes dues à
chaque renouvellement de titre de séjour
elle concourt très clairement à
maintenir les étrangers régulièrement
établis sur le territoire dans une forme
d'insécurité administrative donc on a
vraiment là tous les travers de ce type
de rajout dans dans un texte tel que
celui-là monsieur Balan je crois que
tout a été dit donc il est
défenduente merci monsieur le Président
amendement identique et pour les mêmes
raisons donc défendu monsieur le
rapporteur je présume favorable
favorable je ve simplement ajouter que
ce qui doit nous préoccuper ce sont les
parcours
d'intégration avons fait d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure et nous n'étions pas d'accord
concernant le regroupement familial et
la question du français dès le pays
d'origine de la même façon il me semble
et j'insiste sur ce point que la
proposition du Sénat multiplie en
réalité les obstacles au parcours
d'intégration notamment pour l'obtention
de la carte de résident de 10
ans Monsieur
gilet oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues vous voudriez là supprimer en
fait les mesures propr à limiter la
délivrance des titres de séjour et vous
vous demandez pourquoi ces mesures sont
présentes dans ce texte quand même 80 %
des Français réclament que l'on prenne
des décisions fermes en matière
d'immigration rien que cela ça devrait
vous parler 63 % des Français estiment
qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en France ça
aussi ça devrait vous parler 73 % des
Français considèrent que la politique
migratoire française est trop laxiste ça
aussi ça devrait vous parler 83% des
Français sont favorables par ailleurs à
l'organisation d'un référendum tout ça
ça devrait vous parler on est ici les
représentants du peuple français alors
pourquoi Monsieur le Rapporteur ou
mesdames Messieurs les élus de de gauche
qui ont présenté cet amendement de
suppression pourquoi vous voulez
gauchiser ce texte alors même que les
Français réclament de la fermeté en
matière
d'immigration monsieur kbrat oui merci
parce que bon entendre des chiffres
répétés que ça soit sur les eqtf ou sur
un sondage donnant des 80 70 2000 % ça
aucun sens moi je vais partir de
témoignage d'une association qui
travaille sur les couples binationaux
qui s'appellent les amoureux au banc
public au banc public pas comme
malheureusement la chanson de Gen
brassins mais plutôt au banc de la
société une série de témoignages je
pense que tout est fait pour nous
décourager défourir et moquerie de la
part des représentants des représentants
des institutions françaises AER un
étranger est donc interdit ici que faire
oublier le rêve de fonder une famille et
de devenir parents force et de constater
que mon pays que je chérri tant me
refuse aujourd'hui le droit de fonder
une famille et qui s'occupera de ma
femme si je repars pour plus d'un mois
en Algérie si je tiens à apporter mon
soutien à tous ces couples qui s'aiment
mais connaissent des difficultés
inacceptables je pourrais continuer he
je vous invite à aller voir ce site
cette association àer rencontrer ces
couples binationaux qui font la force de
notre pays étant donné que je suis
moi-même un enfant binational ce que
vous dites depuis le départ depuis 2
jours de débat je trouve profondément
dégueulasse donc votons C pression et
passons les AM sérieux pour parler de
l'immigration madame
yououfa merci monsieur le Président je
souhaitais répondre à la question qui a
été posée sur pourquoi protéger des élus
qui seraient spécifiquement visés par
des étrangers je vais témoigner
puisqu'il s'agit ici d'entendre les
témoignages des violences que subissent
les élus à Mayotte de la part des
étrangers parce que nous clamons notre
attachement à la France je veux vous
rappeler que les deux dernières ces deux
dernières années trois bâtiments publics
l'interco de Petite Terre l'interco de
Kungu ont été incendiés suite en grande
partie aux opérations de destruction des
bidonvilles de wambouchou parce qu'il a
fallu détruire des habitats clandestins
occupés majoritairement par des
étrangers sur des terrains qui ont des
propriétaires ou des terrains public
donc ce n'est pas une abstraction mais
puisque vous voulez vous donne des
exemples concrets nombre de mes
collègues élus à Mayot ont été attaqués
physiquement certains ont été blessés
par arme blanche moi j'étais terminer ma
campagne sous protection militaire parce
que je suis menacée parce que je défends
maotte française donc non avoir une
protection spécial pour les élus n'est
pas superfettatoire je vous
remercie madame Chatelin
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
moi j'entends les les propos de nos
collègues qui brossent un tableau
absolument
idylique vous n'ignorez pas qu'il y a
des mariages de complaisance vous
n'ignorez pas qu'il y a des unions qui
sont prononcées pour régulariser la
situation d'immigrés en situation
irrégulière et
durcir c'est aussi mettre à l'épreuve et
éventuellement
déjouer des manœuvres qui visent toute
autre chose que la réalisation d'une
union qui soit fondé sur la réalité de
de de sentiments et de désir de vie
commune voilà tout simplement c'est pour
qui a exercé des responsabilités moi
j'ai dû prononcer le mariage d'un
étranger en situation irrégulière en
étant mire parce que la loi ne me permet
pas d'empêcher le mariage d'une personne
en situation irrégul et bien ça m'a
profondément merci Mad ça m'a dérangé
parce que je me suis interrogé sur la
fiabilité de cette union alors il y a
tellement de brois que quand j'ai appelé
madame Chatelin c'est Madame jeev qui a
parlé il y a pas de problème parce que
vous étiez inscrite juste après madame
jeunevard donc on va finir la discussion
avec Madame Chatelin enavant merci
monsieur le Président alors la première
chose madame jeunevir heureusement que
vous respectez la loi et que vous ne
pouvez pas décider qui peut ou ne peut
pas se marier et qu'aujourd'hui mais ça
a été très bien dit par mon collègue un
français ou une Française a le droit
d'aimer et de se marier avec un étranger
et je voudrais répondre à l'argument
mais que vous avez réutilisé
malheureusement madame jeunevard mais
celui duurn qui vit dans un autre monde
un monde où d'un côté les étrangers et
de l'autre côté les Français et bien
aujourd'hui C finalement C Tom vient à
rendre plus difficile la vie des
Français ou des françaises qui
choisissent de se marier avec un
étranger donc en fait quand vous faites
cela non seulement vous pénalisé et vous
rendez la vie plus compliquée
effectivement de personnes dont la seule
faute est de d'être pas né en France
mais vous rendez plus difficile la vie
de de français de françaises qui sont
comme vous le diriez vous même né ici et
qui ont fait le choix de s'unir et de
fonder une famille avec quelqu'un qui
n'est pas né en France voilà l'objectif
de cet amendement et vraiment je vous le
redis en fait oui nous vivons dans un
pays mélangé multiculturel monsieur le
rapporteur vous vouliez dire un mot
avant qu'on passe au vote oui je voulais
simplement apporter un éclairage à
Madame
jeunevard s'agissant de la lutte contre
les mariages frauduleux il y a des
dispositions dans le texte qui ont été
qui ont été ajouté par le par le le
Sénat et nous aurons l'occasion d'en
parler à l'occasion de l'article 7 bis
de la même façon que dans la loi
séparatisme don j'avais l'honneur déjà
d'être rapporteur général nous avons à
l'époque renforcé les capacités
d'opposition du
maire au mariage qu'il jugeait le
caséchant frauduleux et là l'article 7
bis fait intervenir le procureur de la
République sur un surcis supplémentaire
à à mariage donc je je suis d'accord
avec vous mais la situation que vous
évoquez et l'amendement que
en tout cas l'article du du Sénat ne
répond pas à cette situation en rien
puisque ça n'est pas le passage de 3
années de résidence en France à 5 ans
qui résoudra la question du mariage
frauduleux ni à 3 ans ni à 5 ans en
réalité le mariage frauduleux il faut
tout de suite s'y intéresser et dès le
risque de fraude et pas et donc
j'imagine mal que la situation de portée
de 3 ans à 5 ans de résidence en France
apporte la moindre solution possible à
la question d'un éventuel mariage forcé
5 ans ou 3 ans auparavant en revanche
cette condition de résidence pour
accéder supplémentaire de 3 ans à 5 ans
elle pose des problèmes pour l'étranger
marié un ressortissant français car ça
touche cette situation elle pose un
problème pour le père ou la mère d'un
enfant mineur Français résidant en
France et ce sont ces situations que
nous visons et nous pensons que pour ces
situations il n'y a pas nécessité de
multiplier les obstacles à l'intégration
parce que ils sont sur la voie
évidemment de
l'intégration je mets donc au voix ces
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
les amendements de
suppression qui vote
contre donc ils sont
adoptés l'article est supprimé pour
l'article 1er e monsieur Lucas le
198 merci Monsieur le le président les
restrictions prévu à à cet article vont
rendre le droit au séjour rendraz le
droit au séjour pour raisons médicales
inopérant aujourd'hui une personne
étrangère gravement malade résidante en
France peut solliciter un droit au
séjour pour raison de santé si elle ne
peut pas bénéficier effectivement d'un
traitement approprié dans son pays
d'origine cette notion d'effectivité est
essentielle elle permet de prendre en
compte les éventuelles difficultés
d'accès aux soins qu'elles soit de
nature économique coup des traitement
absence de couverture maladie
géographique ou lié à des situations de
de discrimination
le projet de loi remplace le critère
d'effectivité par un critère de
disponibilité de traitement il suffirait
que le traitement soit formellement
disponible sans pour autant être
accessible à l'ensemble de la population
pour priver la personne d'un titre de
séjour en France et l'expulser dans son
pays d'origine malgré le risque
d'aggravation de sa maladie on est là
dans dans une disposition qui mettrait
en danger la vie de plusieurs
milliers de personne et il nous paraît
là aussi qu'on va vraiment dans dans
l'horreur de ce texte qu'il faut
supprimer C
article
merci de me donner la parole donc pour
aller dans dans le même sens l'on
continue brick après brick à trouvver
toutes les possibilités pour rendre la
vie des étrangers ou leur
possibilités de venir chez nous tout à
fait impossible et pour le mode de vie
tout à fait infernal nous affirmons
d'autant plus que cette affaire là ne
repose pas sur la raison mais a un
caractère idéologique euh dans la mesure
où ces situations sont finalement
relativement peu relativement peu
répandu et surtout sont en baisse d'une
façon qui est tout à fait significative
moi je pense qu'il serait plus simple et
plus efficace que de se dire les choses
comme elles sont voilà on a décidé que
la France était plus le pays des droits
de l'homme et ben passons par là
d'ailleurs ça a été dit he il faut
sortir de la CEDH moi j'ai jamais
entendu un truc aussi incroyable que ça
du point de vue du droit et du point de
vue de ce que la France représente bah
allons-y comme ça le 605 n'est pas
défendu le 859 qui le défend monsieur
valallot
oui merci Monsieur le le Président on a
là un amendement qui remet en question
de façon inconsidérée ni justifié ni
souhaité un droit au séjour des
étrangers des étrangers malades qui
était un acquis des grandes luttes des
années 90
au moment de l'épidémie du sida et c'est
un retour en réalité à ce que la droite
avait déjà accompli c'est-à-dire la loi
ortefeu de 2011 que nous avions aboli en
2000 en 2016 et qui en réalité ne se
préoccupe plus de l'effectivité de
l'accès à un certain nombre de
traitements et de médicaments mais se
contente que cela existe dans le pays
dont l'étranger est originaire ayons en
tête que c'est un un titre de séjour qui
est accordé à des gens qui sont déjà
présent en France n'est pas un visa et
il y a là sans aucun doute une confusion
avec notamment le le dispositif de visa
vis sanitaireom pas j'ai plus plus le
titre madameon le
suivant cette un autre jour
maisci
Monsieur effectivement pour compléter ce
que disait cèue il sagit pas mais bien
d'un titre de séjour accordé à des
personnes déjà présentes que en
regardant les débats au Sénat
honnêtement je n'ai pas vu
d'argumen un peu tangible pour expliquer
le pourquoi à part une recherche de
remise en cause de tous les titres de
séjour pour limité pour les limiter je
redis que la notion d'effectivité est
absolument essentielle parce qu'elle
permet de de prendre en compte les les
éventuelles difficultés d'accès aux
soins de nature économique géographique
ou encore lié à des situations de
discrimination que celui-ci avait déjà
été supprimé par la loi baisson et non h
de feu pour être réinstauré en mars 2016
constatant qu'effectivement cette
effectivité avait un réel sens qu'elleit
un élément fondamental d'appréciation du
besoin de de prise en charge en France
d'une personne gravement malade merci
Madame
chassagol merci monsieur le Président
donc c'est aussi un amendement de
suppression de ce nouvel article qui
restraint l'accès au titre de séjour
étranger malade pour des étrangers
résidants en France je le répète mais
c'est important qui ont besoin d'un
traitement dont le défaut pourrait avoir
des conséquences graves les sénateurs
ont rétabli le critère restrictif qui
prévalait jusqu'en 2016 de l'absence
d'un traitement approprié dans le pays
d'origine or un traitement peut exister
sans être pour autant accessible pour
des raisons de coût de distance d'un
entourage nécessaire cette restriction
priverait donc des personnes gravement
malades de leurs soins sous prétexte
qu'un traitement existerait dans leur
pays d'origine même si elles n'y ont pas
accè accès sachant que la part des
titres octroyé sur ce motif est faible
mais aussi que près d'un tiers des
bénéficiaires a on recours pour soigner
des maladies infectieuses du type VIH
hépatite B ou C mettre fin à cette
solidarité contre la diffusion du VIH
par exemple serait particulièrement
problématique pour la santé des
étrangers concernés mais aussi pour
notre système de soins et pour la santé
mondiale monsieur la
tomombe défendu madame alors madame
duont merci monsieur le Président dans
la continuité de de l'expression des
collègues et de Madame chassagnol en
particulier qui a été très complète moi
il me semble au final que
cette nouvelle attaque en définitive en
direction des étrangers euh est
symbolique plus que effective puisque ça
concerne 3000 malades étrangers par an
donc un chiffre extrêmement réduit en
définitive donc on est dans dans
l'agitation du du symbole et et je le
regrette d'où c'est cet amendement de
suppression j'ai également déposé un
amendement de suppression de cet article
pour les questions de stock qui viennent
d'être évoqué par Madame chassagnol pour
des questions de rupture d'accès au
droits qui viennent qui ont été présenté
par la Défenseur des droits dans son
audition et parce que cet cette
dispositif a été en très forte
diminution puisqu'on a compté plus de
5000 étrangers malades accueillis en
2019 et qu'on est en 2021 à 3900 ce qui
montre que nous n'avons pas besoin de
restrictions supplémentaires sur cette
sur ce type de sjours c'est la raison
pour laquelle je demande comme comme mes
collègues la suppression de cet article
monsieur le
rapporteur merci Monsieur le le
président quelques quelques éléments
d'abord effectivement contrairement à ce
que j'ai pu lire par exemple dans une
euh une interpellation de la part de la
directrice générale de de du site
d'action
euh il ne s'agit pas euh d'accompagner
sur le plan médical des personnes qui se
trouveraiit en dehors du territoire
national en aucune manière il s'agit
bien d'accompagner euh des personnes qui
sont cela a été dit à plusieurs reprises
par Madame fossillon Monsieur Vallot en
particulier d'accompagner des personnes
qui sont présentes et qui réside
habituellement c'est le titre la
question précise sur le territoire
national donc concrètement concrètement
elle bénéficie d'un
visa soit elles peuvent être aussi
demandeur d'asile et demander le titre
étranger malade ont tout à fait la
possibilité de le faire ce sont bien
donc des personnes qui résident
habituellement en France depuis un an
lorsque la directrice générale du C
d'action m'accuse de
vouloir accélérer d'une certaine façon
les 10000 morts dit-elle du VIH en 2021
au Cameroun les 50000 morts au Nigeria
les 85000 en Afrique du Sud je pourrais
ajouter les 1000 elle ne le cite pas au
Sénégal qui est un pays que je connais
particulièrement bien ce sont des décès
qui hélas sont indépendants de
l'application du titre étranger malade
je je veux quand même le redire parce
que j'ai l'impression que parfois il y a
une confusion euh et évidemment toutes
ces personnes ne peuvent pas obtenir un
titre étranger malade ou alors pas en
tout cas systématiquement être soigné
par tous les pays qui disposeraient
d'une offre de soins qui serait
supérieure à celle de ces pays ça c'est
important de le
rappeler sur les étrangers malades
monsieur le président l'a dit à à
l'instant et de façon très précise on
est sur un dispositif étroit
3750 personnes 3900 3750 personnes qui
en bénéficie aujourd'hui ce que j'ai
c'est de regarder après le Sénat ça
n'est pas la mesure symbolique c'est
est-ce qu'il y a dans le dispositif
étranger malade des sources possibles
d'amélioration moi j'en voie
quelquesunes je propose àa Martin
qu'elle prenne un ver deut si elle le
souhaite je peux lui servir
même quelle est quelle est la les
situations sur lesquelles je pense que
nous devons pouvoir regarder les choses
de façon
précise aujourd'hui le titre étranger
malade est Inter dit à tout
ressortissant de la nationalité de l'un
des États membres de l'Union européenne
ça paraît normal ce sont des États qui
bénéficient d'un système de soins qui
est tout à fait approprié pour des
pathologies qui pourraient être
concernées en revanche un ressortissant
d'un pays
tiers qui vit en Allemagne par exemple
qui ne peut pas accéder à un titre
étranger malade en Allemagne car il n'y
a pas de titre étranger malade en
Allemagne il y a la France uniquement et
il y a la Belgique peut demander le
titre étranger malade en
France et là je trouve qu'il y a euh une
incohérence et peut-être même une
injustice mes chers collègues bon il y a
un système de soins allemand qui est
tout à fait
performant et cette personne va pouvoir
venir demander en France un titre auquel
elle n'a pas dans le pays dans lequel
elle réside habituellement et nous
allons éventuellement pouvoir lui
accorder cette possibilité très
sincèrement je ne sais pas expliquer
cette
disposition autre autre cas de non non
mais discutons vous me répondrai je vous
donne mes éléments
d'appréciation autre autres situation
pointé et ce sont des des situations qui
sont à la marge monsieur de la porte
j'en suis vraiment clair làdessus des
personnes de nationalité
américaine de nationalité
américaine peuvent dans les mêmes
conditions accéder au titre étranger
malade de la même façon il y a un
système de soins aux États-Unis qui le
permet d'accéder aux soins concernés
aujourd'hui nous avons des personnes de
nationalité Georgienne il y en a 3000 en
France aujourd'hui qui bénéficient d'un
titre étranger malade il y a comme l'a
dit à l'instant monsieur le Président un
stock pardon pour ce terme qui est un
délicat pour les personnes concernées
3000 personnes sont dialysé en France
sont geéorgiennes dans un pays dont le
système de soins est parfaitement
accessible avec gratuité des soins par
assurance maladie cela pose un problème
je vous encourage vivement à demander au
directeur général de l'hphp quelle est
la situation pour ces cas de figure et
puis je terminerai sur un dernier cas de
figure qui me semble aussi important de
livrer à votre
réflexion la situation d'une personne de
nationalité de la nationalité d'un pays
tiers qui obtient le titre étranger
malade pour réaliser une PMA je crois
très sincèrement que ce sont des
éléments de dévoiement du titre étranger
malade le titre étranger malade il a été
créé pardon mes chers collègues il a été
créé de mémoire je crois que c'est en
1989 pour répondre à une situation et
c'est la situation que Clara chagol
indiqu il y a quelques instants et donc
je vais essayer de lu répondre sur ce
point de façon très précise il a été
créé en
1989 pour venir en aide et accompagner
les malades du VIH qui ne pouvait pas
bénéficier de trithérapie à l'exception
de quelques pays dans le monde à
l'exception de quelques pays dans le
monde et la France a pris alors sa
responsabilités ses
responsabilités depuis cette époque il
n'y a pas eu d'explosion du nombre de
titres étrangers malades en aucune
manière cela a été dit par monsieur le
président de la commission des lois il y
a en revanche des situations qui ne sont
pas des situations
compréhensibles il compris pour nous
législateurs donc ce que je vous
propose et pardon pour
je réponds pardon tout de suite a
clarcheagol avec les aménagements que je
vais DISP que je vais proposer dans
l'amendement les situations que vous
avez évoqué de VI sont évidemment pris
en compte c'est une absolue nécessité
personne ne peut imaginer personne ne
peut imaginer qu'une personne souffrant
du VIH présente habituellement en France
soit obligé de retourner dans son pays
d'origine pour une offre de soins
qu'elle n'aura peut-être pas donc cette
situation évidemment doit être
absolument préservée moi je vous
proposerait de conserver une partie et
une partie seulement de l'expression
employée par le Sénat le Sénat je
simplifie revient à la disposition ce
qui montre qu'elle n'est pas
inacceptable d'avant 2016 c'est-à-dire
de regarder l'accès effectif à l'offre
de soins ça c'est la version qui a été
mise en place en
2016 le Sénat nous dit on ne regarde pas
simplement l'accès effectif on regarde
s'il y a une offre de soins attention si
on il y a une offre de soins évidemment
que l'appréciation va se faire au regard
aussi de la situation nationale bon ce
que je vous propose c'est que nous
puissions conserver
effectivement la partie de la
formulation du Sénat sur les traitements
appropriés dans le pays concerné le pays
d'origine mais que nous
intégrions une réserve d'interprétation
possible par le préfet en lien avec les
médecins de l'OFI concernant les motifs
humanitaires exceptionnels voilà les
éléments que j'apporte à votre réflexion
j'ajoute une dernière chose parce que je
pense qu'il faut présenter les éléments
dans leur globalité le Sénat proposé de
regarder le traitement approprié et pas
simplement l'accès effectif je vous ai
indiqué quelle réponse j'entendais
apporter à travers l'amendement il
comptait aussi il propose pardon que il
n'y ait pas de remboursement par
l'assurance maladie des soins qui
seraient apportés aux étrangers malades
là je crois que c'est inacceptable et
c'est même complètement contradictoire
avec ce que l'assemblée national a pu
adopter il y a désormais quelques années
avec la Puma avec la Puma qui au
contraire veut assumer une couverture
universelle et donc je vous proposerai
de renoncer à la suppression plutôt au
non remboursement affirmé par le Sénat
par l'assurance maladie et puis
dernièrement pour finir le Sénat
souhaite modifier la la la définition
des conséquences d'une exceptionnelle
gravité qui est l'une des conditions
pour accéder au titrre étranger malad le
Sénat souhaitit en fait inspiré de
l'arrêté de 2017 qui définit ce que sont
ces conséquences d'une ex gravité et en
réalité en reprenant l'arrêté 2017 il en
profite pour durcir la définition de ces
conséquences exceptionnelles d'une
exceptionnelle gravité je je souhaite
par conséquent en rester à l'écriture
strict au sinus de l'arrêté de 2017 qui
me paraît beaucoup plus cohérent qui
introduit une souplesse que le Sénat n'a
pas souhaité et qui permettra de mettre
dans la loi des dispositions pourquoi
pas de nature
réglementaire madame
yousoufa je souhaitais alimenter le
débat en vous parlant de la situation
évidemment à Mayotte parce que je
rappelle que notre hôpital dans notre
désert médical reçoit un patient sur
deux qui est étranger et que pour le
contexte rappelé à la représentation
nationale que ce que vous votez va
s'appliquer à l'ensemble du territoire
sauf Mayotte parce qu'à Mayotte on nous
explique parce que nous sommes cernés de
pays pauvres très très très très pauvres
il vaut mieux ne pas développer la santé
à Mayotte pour éviter un appel d'air
donc on prive vos
compatriotes de
santé parce que il y a trop de pauvreté
autour non mais parce qu'il faut quand
même comprendre que là les principes que
vous énoncez on quand même face au réel
des limites entre autres celles de la
dépense publique parce que quand vous
dépensez 1 € à Mayotte pour la santé de
manière dérogatoire avec une enveloppe
unique parce qu'on ne veut pas mettre en
place la sécurité sociale parce qu'il y
a TR d'immigration clandestine
50 centimes de 7 €os va pour les
étrangers madame louvagi
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur pour les
explications que vous avez donné au
moins en qualité de rapporteur spécial
de la mission santé qui a dans son dans
sa mission le le programme de l'aide
médicale d'État je me suis intéressé au
titre de séjour pour soins et
effectivement je je je valide que le
dispositif qui a été créé dans les
années
1990 ciblé à l'époque il faut retrouver
l'origine et l'objectif les étrangers en
situation irrégulière atteint du sida et
essentiellement des africains ou des
Haïtiens c'était l'objectif qui avait
été retenu aujourd'hui fort est de
constater plus de 25 ans après que
l'admission au séjour pour soins est
devenue ça n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'OFI dans le cadre d'un
questionnaire que j'ai réalisé soit un
moyen de migration médicale avec une
prise en charge assurée par la France et
le rapport IgA cigf le soulligne soit
une une opportunité pour obtenir un
séjour régulier donc ce que veut faire
le Sénat aujourd'hui de réduire et va
plutôt dans le bon sens je rappelle que
le dispositif c'est une exception en
Europe et une exception dans le monde et
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez donné
un nombre je vais juste terminer
Monsieur le Président 3200 primau
demandeurs c'est
30000 Monsieur de la
porte allez-y non en fait faut faut
essayer de rester calme dans une soirée
comme ça parce que c'est vrai que le le
rapporteur a présenté un long exposé un
peu fumeux mais j'en déduis une chose
c'est qu'il a gardé du Sénat la
suppression de
l'effectivité pour pouvoir avoir accès
au titrre de séjour ça veut dire quoi
l'effectivité ça veut dire que en gros
on ne prend pas en compte le caractère
de l'inaccessibilité socio-économique ou
des circonstances exceptionnelles lié à
la situation personnelle de la personne
qui ferait qu'il n'aurait pas forcément
accès à ses soins dans son pays
d'origine par ailleurs je suis
représentant de l'Assemblée au Conseil
national du sida donc vous avez eu des
propos que j'ai trouvé assez déplaisants
vis-à-vis d'une personne qui intervient
dans le domaine j'ai pris les chiffres
des nationalités alors il y a évidemment
on n' pas la on sait pas de quel pays
ils viennent parce que vous évoquez
l'histoire du pays-tiers depuis l'Europe
mais vous êtes incapable de donner des
chiffres non plus monsieur le rapporteur
parce que tout simplement depuis 2021
l'ofie n'a pas fourni son rapport annuel
obligatoire sur la question de l'accès
aux soins deuxièmement l'OFI a fait en
sorte qu'il y a deux fois moins de
titres qui sont délivrés pour soin et ça
c'est un vrai problème aussi auquel il
faudra répondre monsieur marcangéi merci
monsieur le Président nous allons voter
contre ces amendements de suppression
euh il faut bien comprendre que ce titre
il n'existe plus nulle part mis à part
chez nos amis belges d'après plusieurs
études les bénéficiaires de ces titres
de séjour viennent essentiellement de
pays de l'OCDE cela a été rappelé par le
rapporteur général on connaît la qualité
des systèmes de soins de ces pays il
nous paraît dès lors pertinent de
s'assurer que ce titre ne soit réservé
qu'aux personnes qui viennent de pays où
le traitement demandé n'existe tout
simplement pas et d'ailleurs nous
proposerons tout à l'heure un amendement
allant dans ce sens donc nous voterons
contre les amendements de suppression
Monsieur
riman Merci monsieur le Président je ne
serai pas long de mon propos juste pour
dire deux choses la première c'est que
par rapport à l'exposé du rapporteur
général euh nous maintenons le fait que
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article là nous ne sommes pas nous
sommes pas nous sommes en désaccord sur
sur l'approche donc là-dessus il y a pas
de souci et deuxième chose euh je tiens
attirer l'attention de de la
représentation nationale sur le fait que
sur ce texte de loi le traitement qui
est fait par rapport au territoire de
Mayotte est inacceptable et inadmissible
je ne peux pas comprendre moi en tant
que Français que Mayot pour X raisons ne
puisse pas être logé de la même manière
que les autres territoires français
d'accord là il y a un problème de fond
dans ce qu'on est en train de faire ce
soir en matière de législative c'est pas
normal ce qui se passe monsieur
rapporteur général donc je j'espère
qu'il y aura une revoyure de posture sur
le sujet parce que on va pas accepter
nous en tant que moi en tant
qu'ultramarin on va pas accepter que
Mayot soit toujours de côté concant les
dispositifs sociaux qui sont appliqués
sur le territoire français je vous
remercie monsieur Lucas merci monsieur
le Président plusieurs points qui
suivent ça forment une ligne et la votre
monsieur le rapporteur général c'est
plus hypocrite qu'hyppocrate vous savez
ce serment qui oblige à à soigner et il
y a quand même dans cette ligne des
choses qui ne peuvent que nous effarer
de l'Ave de sagesse du gouvernement sur
la suppression de l'aide médicale des
cas au Sénat et nous en parlerons dans
quelques instants à votre remise en
cause ici de l'effectivité des soins
dont nous vous av avons démontré avec
des collègues de tous les bancs de
toutes les sensibilités politiques
qu'elle allait mettre en cause gravement
l'accès aux soins d'un certain nombre de
personnes qu'elle allait engendrer des
difficultés sanitaires énormes tout ça
avec l'alerte de nombreuses associations
dont Médecin du Monde dont j'ai ici le
plaidoyer sous les yeux comment
pouvez-vous dans un
monsieur de la porte a dit fumeux dans
un un exposé fumeux comme ça essayer de
nous endormir en nous disant voilà il y
a un compromis il y a une synthèse vous
vous alignez sur la droite radicalisée
sur l'extrême droite sur un sujet
essentiel qui est celui de la santé et
de la santé publique monsieur
Gouffier merci Monsieur le le président
j'entends les questionnements des
collègues à travers ces différents
amendements moi je tiens à saluer
l'exposé du rapporteur général qui entre
nous n'était pas fumeux non était très
clair été clair sur l'historique du
dispositif qui au passage existait avant
2016 sous un autre format et c'était pas
un dispositif pensé par l'extrême droite
euh qui avait évolué sur son historique
sur les raisons de l'existence de ce
dispositif qui pointe aussi les
incohérences et effectivement le
dévoiement qui peut que l'on peut
observer de ce titre aujourd'hui qui ne
doit pas nous interdire de travailler
dessus c'est ce que nous propose le
rapporteur général afin que nous
retrouvions l'efficacité je pense vous
entièrement de ce dispositif qui Laurent
marangé le rappelé tout à l'heure
n'existe plus que dans notre pays et la
Belgique je crois donc nous voterons le
groupe rnaissance contre ces amendements
de
suppression monsieur kbrat
enfin la Guinée conar la
Guinée a la possibilité de donner
l'accès au traitement contre le VIH la
trithérapie elle n'est pas accessible
financièrement de par l'état de la
Guinée aux personnes atteint du vie
Haïti peut en effet aussi donner ce
traitement la trithérapie mais les
personnes sur place n'ont pas accès je
vois que cet amendement en fait ne va
que affaiblir notre principe de
solidarité qui devrait être celui de la
6e puissance économique mondiale
c'est-à-dire de d'être capable de
prendre en soin et de lutter
efficacement par rapport aux engagement
qu'on a vis-à-vis de l'ONU de l'ONU sida
sur la volonté d'éradiquer l'épidémie du
VIH à travers le monde et là vous
proposez de durcir et vous avez fait une
remarque monsieur le rapporteur qui
m'étonne parce que M' vous avez parler
de l'ordonnance de
2017 sur la possibilité de
renvoi en France nous renvoyons déjà
dans des pays qui ne sont incapables de
traiter le VIH des personnes atteintes
du
VIH au bout d'un moment l'inhumanité
fait que monsieur le rapporteur
oui quelques quelques éléments
supplément supplémentaire peut-être de
dans nos
échanges monsieur cabra ce que vous
dites à l'instant précisément le titre
étranger malade ne peut pas et ne pourra
pas et n'a jamais pu y répondre à cette
situation un ressortissant qui est
présent actuellement dans son pays
d'origine qui souffre d'une pathologie
particulière qui nécessite un
accompagnement VIH par exemple ne peut
pas prétendre au titre étranger malade
puisque le titre étranger malade n'est
accepté n'est accessible qu'à un
ressortissant de nationalité étrangère
présent sur le territoire national
depuis 1 an depuis un an et donc
comprenons bien la logique du titre
étranger malade il s'agit de dire que la
personne au regard de son système de
soins ou du système plutôt de soins de
son pays d'origine ne va pas revenir
dans son pays alors qu'elle est
souffrante en France c'est ça l'étranger
malade et de de façon à ce qu'il y ait
un comportement humanitaire de la part
de la France et cela a été créé cela a
été expliqué à plusieurs reprises pour
faire face notamment à à l'ensemble des
pays qui n'avaient pas de traitement
approprié contre le vage dans les années
80 et ensuite avec l'apparition de la
trithérapie donc le titre étranger
malade il s'agit de dire à la personne
qui est malade ici en France présente
depuis un an oui nous acceptons de
prendre en charge vos soins et vous
n'allez pas revenir dans votre pays
d'origine c'est ça donc ça n'est pas le
Guinéen présent dans son pays sans quoi
pardon de vous le dire mais alors nous
aurions des dizaines de milliers de
titres étrangers malades donnés chaque
année quel est le dispositif pour les
sortissant nationalité étrangère en
France il y a trois voies je vous le
rappelle il y a laame nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler il y a ensuite
le dispositif de soins urgents
dispositif de soins urgents qui est
d'ailleurs mis en place à Mayotte
c'est-à-dire ce sont les hôpitaux
directement qui sont chargés des
difficultés et il y a ensuite des
transferts de charges du budget de
l'État vers le budget des des hôpitaux
de la sécurité social et puis il a
ensuite le titre étranger malade moi ce
que je crois important lorsqu'on est
législateur c'est c'est de regarder les
cas qui au fond n'ont plus à être
traités par ce titre de séjour c'est
simplement ce que je souhaiterais faire
et lorsque je parlais d'individus de
nationalité américaine 2021 vous avez
raison monsieur de laapte il n a pas eu
de de rapport depuis 2021 ce sont 28
ressortissants et j'ai dit que c'était
des éléments marginaux voilà je je
j'indiquais tout à l'heure la situation
de résidents de pays-tiers qui vivent
dans un État de l'Union européenne et
qui viennent donc demander un titre sur
autre sol alors que par exemple en
Allemagne ils ont accès à un système de
soins tout à fait acceptable ce que je
n'accepte pas dans la proposition du
Sénat et il n'y a rien de fumeux
là-dedans monsieur Lucas ce que je
n'accepte pas c'est la disposition
intégrée par le Sénat qu'en plus il
faudrait que l'assurance maladie ne le
prennent plus à charge il faudrait par
conséquent que les personnes de
obtiennent un titre étranger malade ici
mais qu'en plus ell le payent sur un
système d'assurance privée là je trouve
que ce serait particulièrement injuste
pour une proportion je l'ai dit de 3750
€ de 3750 malades et je termine sur un
dernier point pardon d'être un peu long
mais je crois que ce sujet le
mérite ce ce ce que je vous propose avec
cet amendement qui vient modifier la
position du Sénat sur les motifs
humanitaire exceptionnel
c'est une solution qui ne mérite pas les
excès d'injure elle était applicable à
l'amendement PRS que je fais elle était
applicable jusqu'en 2016 jusqu'en 2016
et depuis 2016 la réalité c'est que les
titres étrangers malades sont au fond
stable on est passé de 4 à 4 5000 à
aujourd'hui plutôt 4000 il y a une
stabilité on n pass non mais le stock je
parle du titre des titres délivrés
chaque année donc le système qui était
en place en place jusqu'en 2016 c'est à
peu près celui sur lequel nous pourrions
revenir ne mérite pas l'excès d'injure
et pardon de le dire mais nous avons
vécu sous un gouvernement sur un une
présidence Hollande pendant 5 ans avec
ce dispositif parce que en fait il ne
posait aucune
difficulté qui vote pour les amendements
de
suppression qui vote contre les
amendements de
suppression donc ils sont adoptés ils
sont rejetés pardon
rejeté non ils sont non non c'est c'est
moi qui prononce la décision et je me
suis trompé c'est rejeté non non non non
non quand quand vous avez LR la majorité
et le RN qui vote contre ils sont
rejetés d'accord
monsieur
valotême temps on v pour et onot contre
Monsieur
Vall oui monsieur le le le président moi
je propose un un élargissement des du
droit
au au titre de séjour pour étranger
malade en revenant sur les traumatismes
physiques et psychologiques qui sont
liés au parcours migratoire vous l'avez
peut-être vu la revue The Land 7 a
publié en septembre dernier une grande
enquête sur
273 demandeuses d'asile à Marseille qui
n'avaient pas encore eu leur demande et
qui a fait un tableau dramatique
apocalyptique dont le monde s'est fait
l'écho de leur parcours migratoire et
des cicatrices indélibiles physiquees
psychologique de cette de cette
traversée elle ne relève actuellement ni
de ni forcément de l'asile ni forcément
aujourd'hui du dispositif étranger
malade et donc nous proposons de d'en
élargir le le bénéfice la principale
caractéristique de ces de ces femmes
parce qu'il s'agit beaucoup de femmes
c'est que le viol est souvent ce qui a
commandé leur départ le viol est ce qui
a accompagner leur parcours migratoire
et malheureusement le viol et ce qui
j'allais dire épouse leur arrivée y
compris sur le territoire nationale donc
cette protection supplémentaire madame
en discussion commune oui merci monsieur
le président Président je veux juste
rappeler parce que le nombre de Primo
accédents a été donné par année dans le
dispositif qu'il existe un stock
aujourd'hui de 30000 titres de séjour
pour soins l'amendement qui vous est
proposé vous vous propose de revenir à
un objectif initial qui aujourd'hui a
été détourné je veux rappeler que le
critère de la résidence habituelle en
France est trop souple les étrangers
bénéficient du titre de séjour pour soin
alors qu'ils viennent d'arriver sur le
sol français donc c'est l'objet de cet
amendement cet amendement également
intervient sur le critère de
l'exceptionnelle gravité qui n'a pas la
portée qu'il devrait avoir des étrangers
accèdent au titre de séjour pour soins
alors même que leur pathologie n'est pas
d'une exceptionnelle gravité ce n'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est le dernier
rapport de Lofi et cet amendement vous
propose d'intervenir également sur le
critère de l'existence du soin dans le
pays d'origine qui n'est pas dans les
faits véritablement opérant l'OFI a
d'ailleurs indiquer que des Suisses des
Américains ou encore des Canadiens
bénéficiaient chaque année du titre de
séjour pour soins et je rappeler que
certaines personnes bénéficient de
médicaments relativement coûteux qui
peuvent représenter 1 million d'euros
par an et par
personne monsieur le rapporteur vos avis
sur ces deux
amendements avis défavorable parce que
je crois que la il me semble que la
condition de 2 ans viendrait en revanche
casser le dispositif des titre étranger
malade c'est peut-être le souhait qui
qui est le votre mais je ça n'est pas le
notôtre et sur le l'amendement de
Monsieur Vallot je défavorable parce que
l'OFI fait évidemment ce travable ce
travail dans euh bien sûr que l'OFI dans
l'estimation de la situation de la
personne qui demande le titre étranger
malade elle regarde aussi son parcours
traumatique elle regarde son passé c'est
c'est évidemment son travail donc
défavorable madame
regol merci monsieur le Président euh
oui peut-être qu'aujourd'hui l'offir
prend en compte mais les modifications
que vous proposez de porter font que ce
ne sera plus pris en compte je je R
ajoute que tout à l'heure nous avons eu
en en QAG euh une intervention vibrante
de la ministre sur le viol comme outil
de guerre sur la façon dont le corps des
femmes était toujours utilisé pour faire
souffrir un peu plus que les autres
êtres humains et je pense que la moindre
des choses quand on a eu les discours
poignants en question au gouvernement
qu'on a eu la réponse très claire de la
ministre du parti qui a posé cette
question et a apporter la réponse la
moindre des choses quand on est un temps
soit peu cohérent et qu'on ne joue pas
avec les sentiments c'est de voter à
minima cette
amendement merci monsieur le Président
alors cet amendement revet quand même
caractère faussement humaniste parce que
là ce qui nous est proposé de
reconnaître ce sont les traumatismes
tant physique que psychologique causé
par le parcours migratoire pour
justifier le bénéfice du statut
d'étrangers malad mais la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est pourquoi il y a des
traumatismes psychologiques et bien une
partie de la réponse résite peut-être
dans le fait que aujourd'hui nous avons
nos collègues d'extrême gauche par
exemple mais aussi des associations
immigrationnistes qui viennent vendre du
rêve à des populations désœuvrées et qui
contribuent à les inciter à prendre à
traverser la Méditerranée dans des
conditions absolument déplorables donc
là aujourd'hui vous venez essayer de
vous donner bonne conscience
pour essayer
d'éteindre le drame que vous avez
contribué à allumer donc la seule
politique humaniste c'est celle du
rassemblement national c'est tenir un
discours de vérité et dire à ces
personnes nous n'avons rien à vous
offrir madame
jeev s'il vous plaît on écoute madame
jeunev merci merci monsieur le
Président le rapport que madame louvag a
rédigé est quand même très éclairant
euh de quoi parle-t-on on parle
d'étrangers malades qui ne disposant pas
dans leur pays de certains traitements
je pense par exemple à des molécules
très innovantes viennent en France pour
se faire soigner à des coûts qui sont
quand même considérables dans le tableau
que que Madame louvagie présente dans
son rapport vous avez des traitement
écoutez bien mes chers collègues qui
avoisine le million d'euros par an et
par personne voilà un dispositif qui
coûte presque 100 millions par an il y a
un stock d'étrangers malades de
30000 actuellement en France pour des
coûts de traitement qui sont
considérables et dans l'amendement de
suppression du rapporteur général il
était question que l'assurance maladie
prenne en charge ses traitements merci
quand on songe à nos compatriotes qui ne
peuvent pas se soigner il y a quelque
monsieur monsie de la porte
oui merci monsieur le Président déjà je
viens de faire un premier calcul ça
représente un coût de 3000 € en moyenne
par personne ce qui reste deux fois
inférieur au coût moyen des dépenses de
santé par un habitant français euh s
rencontre des difficultés donc faut
arrêter de dire que les étrangers ils
coûtent plus cher que les Français sur
les soins ils coûtent même moins cher ça
c'est ce que prouvent notamment les
études sur laame deuxièmement pour
revenir aux différentes aux différents
éléments qui ont pu être évoqués sur la
question des soins psychologiques ce
qu'on voit c'est que suite notamment au
transfert à l'OFI de la capacité à
évaluer les situation on a on a observé
que la position des difficultés
psychologiques était passé de la
première à la 4e position ce qui fait
que on a quand même alors que les
personnes arrivent toujours autant
traumatisé par leur parcours migratoire
parce qu'elles ont pu rencontrer aussi
dans leur pays d'origine on prend de
moins en moins en considération cette
question psychologique donc l'amendement
de Monsieur valallot il a cet intérêt et
je reviendrai enfin sur la question que
vous vous évoquz tout à l'heure parce
que il me reste 2 secondes au niveau du
des personnes qui ont acquis de VIH en
France c'est 30 à 50 % alors sur
l'amendement de monsieur valallot qui
vote
pour qui vote contre
rejeté le 1526 qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
monsieur po le le 116 pardon oui merci
président la France est le seul pays
dans le monde à délivrer une carte de
séjour pour soins des étrangers dans les
conditions dont on vient de débattre
excusez-moi monsieur po madame regol
vous laissez monsieur poet
parler donc je redis la France est le
seul pays dans le monde à délivrer une
carte de séjour pour soins à des
étrangers sans conditions de ressource
or le dévoiement de ce dispositif
généreux financé par la solidarité
nationale alors même que de nombreux
Français ont de plus en plus de mal à se
soigner c'est
trans en un simulac de titre de séjour
pour tourisme médical il s'agit de
réformer responsablement cette procédure
d'admission séjour pour soins propose
reprend une des préconisations du
rapport établi par ma collègue Véronique
en le conditionnant à une périe
résidence de années sur le territoire
national monsieur le
rapporteur j'ai indiqué tout à Rais pour
lesqu je suis défavorable madame
Martin
non mais je voulais faire remarquer
outre le fait que le système n'est pas
si généreux que ça la preuve on vient de
tous le dire en L en larg et en travers
même si pour des raisons idéologiques
vous voulez absolument le réduire mais
êtes-vous vraiment certaine que les
Français aent des difficultés d'accès
aux soins au motif de présence
d'étrangers sur le territoire ne
croyez-vous pas plutôt que ce soit cela
soit dû à des logiques d'austérité à des
retraits des de moyens à l'hôpital
public à la recherche publique à la
façon terrible dont sont traités nos
étudiants en médecine un sur un se
suicide tous les 18 jours tant ils sont
maltraités vous savez quoi moi je pense
que le problème il vient plutôt de là
que des étrangers d'ailleurs vous y
portez une responsabilité vous aussi
très particulière pour ce qui concerne
l'austérité madame
châelin merci monsieur le Président moi
j'ai un peu l'impression qu'on tourne en
rond depuis tout à l'heure des chiffres
on été donnés qui sont extrêmement clair
je rappelle c'est 3200 personnes qui
l'année dernière ont bénéficié de ces
tites de séjour à écouté nos collègues
on a l'impression qu'on ferait le tour
du monde pour donner ses titres de
séjour est-ce qu'on pourrait à un moment
écouter un minimum les débats mais la
raison de ma prise de parole est
premièrement pour répondre à ma collègue
madame Diaz qui a eu une prise de parole
voilà une affabulation je pense que
c'était absolument scandaleux il n'y a
pas d'autres mots premièrement d'une
insensibilité absolument totale par
rapport au calvaire que vivent ces
femmes dans leur parcours migratoire et
deuxièmement une espèce une accusation
extrêmement claire sur les raisons pour
lesquelles elles migreraiit ell
migreraiit parce qu'on leur ferait
croire qu'elles sont bien accueillies
madame Diaz en fait c'est simple le
professeur François erand revient sur
les deux premières causes de migration
la première c'est la mondialisation des
études supérieures les gens viennent
étudier la deuxième c'est les conflits
les guerres civiles les interventions
militaires et les persécution en fait ce
sont les femmes qui fuiti les conflits
qui fuit la qui fuit la guerre qui fuit
le en fait qui fuit la violence tout
simplement et qui au cours de leur
parcours subissent ces viols et
subissent ces violences un peu de
respect dans mon parole ser madame
louvagi normalement vous l'avez hein oui
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
effectivement confirmer que le
dispositif dont nous parlons est une
exception en Europe et aussi dans le
monde qu'en Belgique au Luxembourg il
existe un dispositif apparenté mais avec
une procédure d'instruction beaucoup
plus restrictive et c'est important de
le souligner je voudrais juste rappeler
que le critère de l'existence du soin
dans le pays d'origine n'est aujourd'hui
pas opérant ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
l'OFI fait état que des Suisses des
Américains ou encore des Canadiens
bénéfi si chaque année du titre de
séjour pour soins et que le bénéfice de
ce titre de séjour pour soins n'est
soumis à aucune condition de ressources
et quand bien même ces cas restent
marginaux cela témoigne des défaillances
de dispositif je vais vous donner un
chiffre entre 2017 et 2022
5598 ressortissants des pays du G20
5598 ressortissants des pays du G20 ont
déposé une demande de titre de séjour
pour soin voilà donc tout ça montre les
défaillances du système et ne répondent
plus du tout à l'objectif qui avait été
initié par le titre de séjour pour soin
bien et donc sur l'amendement de
Monsieur poet qui vote pour l'amendement
de Monsieur Poget qui vote contre rejeté
madame le suivant monsieur porte le
suivant merci monsieur le Président un
amendement pour ramener un peu
d'humanité nous ce qu'on propose c'est
que la procédure étranger malade soit
rattachée aux ARS ce qui était le cas
avant 2016 parce que là aussi avant
d'être étranger il s'agit d'abord de
personnes malades il s'agit d'êtres
humains qui ont besoin d'être soignés et
de mettre cette procédure sous le la
tutelle du ministère de l'Intérieur s
don sur la vision de ce gouvernement je
ne reviens pas sur qu'a dit mon collègue
Lucas sur les avis de sagesse qui ont
été donnés notamment sur laame au Sénat
et qui donne votre vision du traitement
des maladies et de la santé de personnes
vous les voyez justement comme des
problèmes toujours la cible de
l'étranger jamais vouloir régler les
problèmes de santé ce sont avant tout
des êtres humains et au députés du
rassemblement national qui cible les
étrangers je pense que vous devriez leur
dire merci parce que celles et ceux qui
ont tenu l'hôpital public debout parce
qu'on avait pas de personnel soignant
c'est de très nombreux médecins
étrangers qui heureusement était là pour
assurer la santé publique dans ce
pays monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable monsieur de la
porte allez-y monsieur oui c'est bon je
viens de
réussir juste pour répondre à ce qui
vient d'être dit à l'instant par Madame
louvagi elle nous dit c'est 500
personnes alors déjà moi j'ai pas trouvé
ces chiffres j'ai trouvé trois Canadiens
bon donc c'est pas énorme en
2021 et si on rapporte ça au nombre de
demandes parce que vous évoquez des
demandeurs ça représente moins de 2 %
donc là on est en train de faire tout un
débat pour 2 % c'est donc un débat qui
est purement idéologie démonstratif et
pour rappeler la dépense pour étranger
titre de enfin titre de séjour pour
soins elle est de 1000 € inférieure à la
dépense moyenne par habitant en France
donc faut arrêter aussi de nous de nous
raconter des fadèises en permanence
parce que ça donne derrière les discours
de Madame Diaz c'est-à-dire les
affabulations racistes du rassemblement
national monsieur le
ministre non quelques mots pour dire à
monsieur porte que ces attaques contre
les agents du ministère de l'Intérieur
ne sont pas dignes les policiers les
gendarmes sauvent des vie tous les jours
notamment des personnes quel que soit
leur statut et je pense à ceux qui
plongent dans des EAU à 5 degrés dans la
Manche pour pouvoir sauver des des bébés
c'est aussi le cas des agents de Lofi
qui font un travail très important qui
sont agents du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est le cas des agents de lofpra qui
SAU mais oui mais en insultant en
insultant et
en si si si si vous avez attaqué vous
attaquez quotidiennement vous écoutez le
ministre vous écoutez le ministre vous
attaquez quotidiennement les agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur en expliquant
en expliquant en expliquant qu'ils
auraient beaucoup moins d'humanité que
ceux d'autres ministères je pense qu'il
faudrait que vous changiez d'entienne
parce que c'est des gens qui sauvent
plus de vie je crois que vous ne pensez
il faudrait peut-être les rencontrer les
saluer les remercier Madame
tourinia merci monsieur le Président bon
euh on on a on atteint là vraiment le le
le sommet du du du racisme de des propos
abjects de l'ignomini et Cera moi je
voudrais vous dire quelque chose vous
vous vous dites que les gens viennent en
France pour se faire soigner alors vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi il y a
27000 personnes depuis 9 ans qui ont
pris le risque de traverser la
Méditerranée et qui sont morts en
Méditerranée vous pensez qu'ils étaient
venus pour se faire
soigner bien mais de de qui vous parlez
alors bon allez on se répond pas en
commission je mets au voix la on se tait
parce que je vais passer au vote donc le
574 qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté monsieur le rapporteur le 1649
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
c'est l'amendement que j'ai annoncé il y
a quelques instants qui consiste à
ajouter la la condition de circonstances
humanitair pour couvrir des des
situations qui pourraient être plus
sensibles que d'autres et donc on voilà
la rédaction monsieur Kat
oui je tiens quand même bon vous avez
bien compris qu'on s'opposait de toute
façon généralement à à à cet article et
à la suite d'article mais je vais quand
même répondre rapidement à Monsieur le
Ministre
qui fait de la communication alors pour
plaire à je ne sais qui vu que LR a déjà
annoncé qu'il n'allait pas voter son
projet de loi bon mais ça l'amuse
beaucoup je tiens quand même à rappeler
que monsieur le ministre c'est vous qui
avez plusieurs grèves de la part de l'OF
pra qui vous tombe sous le nez par
rapport à ce projet de loi et demain
d'ailleurs le fra se met en greffe par
rapport à votre projet de loi à votre
politique alors je pense qu'avevec mes
collègues de LR nous serons en désaccord
sur ce projet de loi mais quand les
agents eux-mêmes disent que que ce que
vous faites c'est mal vous ne les
écoutez pas donc monsieur le ministre
moi en réalité renvoyez votre copie et
renvoyz votre texteon va décentraliser
j'ime pas ça monsieur de la porte oui je
vais profiter de la présence du ministre
de l'Intérieur pour lui demander s'il
peut nous expliquer pourquoi Lofi n'a
pas remis son rapport depuis 2 ans sur
la question de la procédure pour
admission pour séjour pour soins ce qui
nous aurait permis d'avoir un débat un
peu plus éclairé moins
démagogique alors je vais mettre au voir
je vais voir mettre au voix l'amendement
du rapporteur qui vote
pour
qui vote
contre alors il est
adopté monsieur marcangéi le suivant
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui vise à préciser les
caractéristiques de pathologie
justifiant la délivrance du titre le
Sénat s'est emborné à inscrire dans la
loi l'appréciation actuellement faite
par les tribunaux administratifs
l'amendement que nous proposons vise à
conditionner la la délivrance d'un tel
type de séjour au seul cas où l'état de
santé nécessite une prise en charge dont
le défaut de par son caractère vital et
immédiat aurait pour la personne des
conséquences d'une exceptionnelle
gravité monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président Marcangeli je
voudrais simplement vous dire sur ce
sujet que je souhaiterais que l'on
puisse conserver ce que le Sénat a a
ajouté à l'article 1er f qui vient et
qui définit précisément les conséquences
d'une exceptionnelle gravité là vous
faites remonter à l'article 1er
les caractères de de définition je pense
qu'il faut garder la cohérence de
l'article 1er f que je vais moi-même
modifier mais vous ajoutez notamment la
question de l'immédiateté au caractère
vital qui existe déjà dans l'article 1er
f nous le verrons dans quelques instants
peut-être pouvons-nous y retravailler
pour la séance au quel cas vous pourriez
peut-être retirer si si vous l'acceptez
monsieur le Président votre amendement
monsieur Marcangeli retirez re je re
monsieur Lucas le
199 monsieur le Président en fait cet
amendement un amendement d'appel à la
seconde délibération monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez refusé la
suppression de cet article qui n'a comme
base que un fantasme idéologique qui
vient juste nourrir cette idée que
finalement l'hôpital français serait en
train d'être fragilisé à cause des
étrangers alors même que ça a été dit la
fragilisation des soins aujourd'hui
c'est principalement le manque de moyens
que vivent aujourd'hui les soignants et
les soignantes donc mon appel monsieur
le rapporteur c'est que nous seront de
retour en séance dans quelques jours
écoutez la sagesse du président de la
commission qui avait déposé un
amendement de suppression suivez-le il
vous reste quelques jours pour se dire
que finalement aider 4000 personnes qui
résident habituellement sur notre
territoire à avoir des soins en fait
c'est juste le minimum
d'humanité monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable monsieur
porte alors attendez rallumez votre
micro parce que même chatin vous l' pas
rendu merci euh monsieur le Président
évidemment on soutien de de cet
amendement qui tente une dernière fois
de vous rappeler à la raison et et on
sera de nouveau dans en bataille dans
l'hémicycle pour tordre le bras ce texte
qui est absolument scandaleux mais pour
vous répondre monsieur le ministre quel
manque de courage de vous cacher
derrière les agents de l'OFI c'est
évidemment pas les agents que je visais
c'est celles et ceux qui donnent les
ordres et celui qui donne les ordres
c'est vous monsieur le ministre donc
vous maltraitez les agents vous
maltraitez celles et ceux qui fuient les
pays en difficulté et vous vous
retranchez derrière vos propres agents
pour ne pas assumer vos responsabilités
c'est vraiment pas très courageux
monsieur le
ministre monsieur
Brun cet amend de nos collègues visent
tout simplement à rétablir ce beau
principe reconnu par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui s'appelle le
principe du secret médical et ce que
propose le texte du Sénat dans cet
article et bien c'est de ne pas
appliquer le secret médical aux
étrangers malades cette exception nous
ne pouvons pas l'accepter de toute façon
elle sera censurée par le Conseil
constitutionnel et le qui l'a rappelé
dans une décision récente le le 11 juin
dernier sur une QPC sur une ordonnance
sur les fonctionnaires il y avait un
dispositif un peu un peu similaire donc
il faut voter cet amendement et je crois
qu'il faut le faire dès la commission
car cette disposition est très
clairement
inconstitutionnelle je mets au voix qui
vote
pour
contre rejeté je mets au voix l'article
1er e qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
adopté
le
577 Monsieur carbra Merci monsieur le
Président donc par cet amendement nous
souhaitons supprimer cet article
introduit par la droite sénatoriale qui
vise à restreindre les possibilités d'Ox
3 d'un titre de séjour aux personnes
gravement malade je pense qu'on a déjà
eu le début de ce débat mais je pense
que il est important de continuer à
aller plus loin sur la question que nous
portons je pense collectivement du
rapport aux soins des autres bon là
monsieur est sûrement
anticonventionnelle on a déjà eu ce
débat mais moi je vais essayer
d'apporter des paroles de chercheurs
parce que je pense que c'est important
d'imenter le débat de chercheur et cet
exemple connu fait par un étudiant à une
anthropologue Marg Margaret Med sur
quelle est la première trace de
civilisation qu'elle peut trouver dans
l'humanité et pour elle ce n'est pas un
outil ce n'est pas l'échange de monnaie
c'est pas l'agriculture c'est la
première tombe dans laquelle on voit un
squelette avec un fmur ressoudé
c'est-à-dire un squelette où il y a eu
un soin médical de sa communauté de son
entourage pour pouvoir perdurer en fait
votre projet de loi vot C article
excusez-moi propose tout simplement une
mesure
antivilisationnelle anilisation c'est à
dire c'est Monsieur car qui volit le
micro merci monsieur le président cet
article 1er f est je crois tout
simplement terrifiant c'est le le
premier mot qui me vient à l'esprit
parce que finalement euh à travers ce
que la le Sénat a introduit on
accueillerait que ceux qui sont vraiment
sur le point de mourir ou ceux qui
verraient leur pronostique vital engagé
s'il ne recevait pas de soins c'est un
un recul considérable et je n'hésite pas
à dire que c'est même un signal terrible
que que l'on adresse et et et l'image de
la France qui est abîmée et qui serait
abîmée par une mesure de ce type-là
il y a dans l'esprit de cet article 1er
f une renonciation totale à toute
considération humanitaire je ne pourrais
pas admettre et comprendre que certains
de de nos collègues ne le voient pas et
et ne votent pas cet amendement de
suppression Monsieur Madame
Rousseau merci monsieur le Président
mais je rejoins les paroles qui viennent
d'être dites cette cet article est
véritablement inhumain c'està-dire que
on dit aux personnes bah écoutez vous
n'êtes pas suffisamment mourante en fait
là donc vous allez repartir parce que
vous n'êtes pas suffisamment en mauvaise
forme et près de la mort et en fait non
seulement c'est inhumain non seulement
ça déroge à tous nos principes
humanitaire de base mais en plus c'est
dangereux et inefficace puisque après
une épidémie comme celle que l'on a
connu il y a 2 ans c'est l'épidémie de
covid on sait à quel point euh les les
virus ne se enfin n'ont pas les mêmes
règles aux frontières et qu'en fait si
vous laissez des gens malades sans soin
de l'autre côté d'une frontière et bien
il y a toutes les chances qu'en plus au
bout d'un moment ça revienne chez nous
donc même à prendre votre logique à vous
de protection de mettre des murs et des
barbelets et de faire en sorte que nous
soyons vraiment très protégés de cette
menace invasive et bien même dans votre
logique ça n'a pas d'efficacité monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président on a
aboli la peine de mort en 19801 certains
cherchent des moyens détourner dans
lesffits de la réhabilité mais c'est ça
dont on parle chers collègues c'est de
la vie ou de la mort de femmes et
d'hommes à qui on regarde là le ma
collègue Rousseau vient vient de le dire
le degré de difficulté qui est leure
quand on parle des questions médicales
quand on parle des questions de santé
c'est bien de vie et de mort dont on
parle et c'est ça je crois dont on doit
prendre la mesure je ne vois pas
d'amendement de suppression du
rapporteur mais j'envoie de collègues de
la majorité je nous exhorte
collectivement parce que nous nous
sommes en France parce que nous sommes
en 2023 à entendre à entendre les
chercheurs mon collègue carbrat l'a
évoqué à entendre les médecins à
connaître à prendre connaissance des
chiffres à à au moins être un peu fidèle
à nos valeurs à nos principes là on est
même pas dans un débat sur l'immigration
sur le curseur de de difficultés pour
rentrer ou pas dans le territoire et
dans tous ces débats là on est sur un un
débat qui touche à ce qu'il y a de plus
essentiel et on a même pas le droit en
tant que parlementaire finalement de
toucher ainsi aux vies humaines merci
Mme
tillon merci Monsieur le le président
bon les les les arguments pour nous
opposer à cette modification ont déjà
été bien expliqué par par mes collègues
je veux simplement dire à quel point
aujourd'hui déjà les mesures mises en
place sont déjà très restrictives je
veux vous faire part par exemple d'une
situation à laquelle j'ai été confronté
comme élu il y a il y a quelques années
d'une d'une maman qui était présente
pour ces deux enfants avec des maladies
dégénérative sur le sol français et euh
un de ces enfants était à l'hôpital et
les médecins avaient expliqué que
c'était la fin pour cet
enfant de semaines avant que cet enfant
meurt elle a reçu une octf considérant
que bah il y avait plus d'extrême
gravité en tout cas qui avait pu le fait
en fait de pouvoir le soigner puisque
les choses étaient finies il a fallu que
j'intervienne pour que cette maman
puisse rester en France pour qu'elle
puisse à la fois voir son premier enfant
mourir et pouvoir soigner le deuxième je
je le dis pas pour faire pleurer dans
les chaumières je le dis pour que à un
moment la question de l'humanité elle
puisse être acccroché peut-être à
quelque chose qui vous parle un enfant
malade un enfant qui va peut-être mourir
et qui en France peut-être soigné voilà
simplement je sais pas si ça va servir à
beaucoup de collègues mais peut-être à
un ou deux monsieur alors madame jacie
Laforge je crois que
elle est pas
signatairesur monsieur Mandon
défendu non mais ENF excusez-moi mais
vous êtes signataire sur les amendement
c'est pas pas défendu Madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président
l'existence donc du titre de séjour
étranger malade permett à un étranger
n'ayant pas pas d'accès effectif au
soins dont il a besoin dans son pays
d'origine d'être soigné en France c'est
donc notre sujet cet article restreint
les conditions d'accès à ce titre le
limitant au prise en charge médicale
engageant le pronostic vital de
l'étranger ou l'altération significative
de l'une de ces fonctions importantes
mais également la mais également tient
compte de la probabilité et du délai
présumé de survenance de ces
conséquences je vous lis cet extrait de
l'article pour vous pour insister sur le
fait que autrement dit cette
modification apportée par le
concentre désormais ou concentrerait si
nous ne le changeons pas l'accès aux
soins pour les malades dont la maladie
est suffisamment avancé pour engager son
pronostic vital donc c'est
contreintuitif par rapport à la pratique
de la France en matière d'humanisme sur
cette question de la santé d'où cet
article de suppression monsieur le
rapporteur vos avis
oui merci Monsieur le le président bon
je ne reviens pas sur le débat que nous
avons eu il y a quelques instants sur
l'le article 1er e nous sommes à
l'article 1er f et que dit cet article
1erier F tel qu'il a été proposé par le
Sénat c'est la reprise auotprè je vais
dire quel mot prê c'est la reprise au
mot prè de l'arrêté 2017 qui définit ce
que sont les conséquences d'une
exceptionnelle gravité il n'y a donc
rien de nouveau dans ce que le Sénat
propose il souhaite faire remonter au
niveau législatif des éléments de
définition qui aujourd'hui sont dans
dans un arrêté de 2017 il y a en
revanche une astuce ce qui ne m'a pas
échappé en tant que rapporteur général
de ce texte c'est que l'un des mots a
été changé et il a été changé pour être
durci et je souhaite par conséquent à
travers l'amendement que je vous
proposerai dans quelques instants le
1650 revenir à la définition telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui inscrite à
l'arrêté 2017 cette modification c'est
c'est la c'est la suivante le Sénat a
souhaité parler d'altération
significative de l'une des fonctions
importantes fonction vitale évidemment
le mot préc de l'arrêté de 2017 c'est
détérioration voyez ça se joue à ça et
donc je proposerai que l'on
réintroduise le mot détériorisation
plutôt que l'expression altération
significative
donc ça change que c'est moins c'est
plus souple mon cher collègue sou très
clairement l'altération significative et
la détérioration interroger des médecins
ils vous répondront que ce n'est pas du
tout la même chose voilà donc le
l'amendement est donc défavorable pour
tous ceux qui souhaiteraient supprimer
le l'article 1er f monsieur
oui merci monsieur le Président pour
pour revenir sur l'amendement 1280 pour
lequel certain nombre d'entre nous au
groupe démocrate n'étaent pas cignataire
nous souhaitons pas supprimer cet
article modulo l'adoption de
l'amendement du du rapporteur qui
solidifie la définition de l'arrêté au
niveau législatif et qui donc donne un
coup de protection supplémentaire à à
l'arrêté ce qui permettrait d'éviter si
nous devions avoir une une arrivée dans
cet hémicycle de personnes qui seraient
mal intentionné de pouvoir le modifier
de façon de façon simple il faudrait
forcément passer par la loi ce qui nous
semble être de bonne à loi madame
Chatelin merci monsieur le Président de
ce côté-là de la salle il y a quand même
l'impression que vous vous moquez un peu
de nous monsieur le rapporteur je suis
désolé de le dire ainsi mais en fait à
un moment assumer c'està dire que tous
les articles qu'on est en train
d'étudier ont un seul objectif c'est de
restraint l'accès au droit pour le
personne étranger donc vous vous jouez
de mot vous remplacez l'altération
significative des fonctions importantes
par la détérioration significative des
fonctions importantes alors c'est
peut-être à peine plus souple non mais
très bien mais donc la première chose
c'est réfléchissez à combien de
personnes vont se voir les portes d'un
hôpital se fermer devant eux parce que
vous vous es joué de mot c'est ça la
vérité la deuxième chose Monsieur le
Ministre c'est que lors des débats au
Sénat vous étiez engagé à nous donner
davantage d'informations sur la
compatibilité de cette rédaction avec la
CEDA la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme nous serions extrêmement
intéressés pour de les avoir avant de
voter il me semble que le Parlement doit
être éclairé je vous remercie monsieur
de la porteis parti surutre
chose je l'avais noté merci c'était pour
poser la même question finalement il y a
eu un engagement ministériel d'apporter
un certain nombre de réponses de poser
aussi des questions aux différentes
autorités par rapport à l'introduction
de l'article 1er f qui avait été
présenté à l'occasion de l'amendement de
suppression par nos collègues
communistes au Sénat et donc donc
monsieur le ministre on attend vos
réponses parce que s'il n'y a pas de
réponse avant le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale on n'est pas éclairé ou alors
vous nous baladez si vous nous baladez
il y a une option soit c'est
conformément ce que dit Monsieur bouer
c'est simplement redire le droit
existant c'est ce que vous dites mais
dans ce caslà il y a pas
d'utilité soit c'est pour envoyer un
message modifier le droit et dans ce
cas-là c'est une
tartuferie monsieur porte je donne la
parole merci monsieur le président
écoutez chaque fois qu'on pense que le
pire est atteint finalement ressurgit
quelque chose d'encore plus horrible
parce que vous changez les mots mais en
vérité c'est comme sur les quotas et sur
les objectifs chiffrés vous réécrivez
mais le sens est le même c'est-à-dire
que des gens vont mourir de cette
décision politique c'est ça que je vous
invite et qu'on vous invite
collectivement à regardz on parle de la
santé on parle de la santé de personnes
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est sur un
débat où on continue de réduire l'accès
aux soins on continue de faire en sorte
que des gens qui sont en extrême
difficulté ne puissent pas être soignés
dans notre pays combien de gens vont
mourir par les décisions politiques qui
sont voté aujourd'hui par des collègues
qui sont dans cette salle c'est ça la
responsabilité qui est la notre nous
sommes sur un débat de santé publique
d'humanité et je vous invite vraiment à
revenir à la raison on parle d'une
décision qui devrait tous nous
rassembler on parle d'être humains de
question de soins et il n'y a pas
d'étranger non étrangers on parle de
gens qui sont malades et qui ont besoin
d'être soignés et la responsabilité et
l'honneur de la France c'est de les
soigner alors madame louvagier et
monsieur le ministre répondra oui merci
Monsieur le le président alors c'est
vrai que il y a une vraie difficulté
d'apprécier finalement les conséquences
d'une exceptionnelle gravité qui
aujourd'hui sont apprécié sur trois
critères le premier c'est le degré de
gravité le second c'est la probabilité
de survenue et le troisème c'est le
délai présumé de survenue de ses
conséquences je voudrais juste vous
rappeler le dernier rapport de l'OFI qui
évoque je le cite la banalisation du
critère des conséquences d'une
exceptionnelle gravité c'est la raison
pour laquelle la rédaction du Sénat
permet de répondre à cette banalisation
du critère et moi monsieur le rapporteur
je suis désolé mais quand vous
substituez au mot l'altération
significative le mot la détérioration
vous n'apportez pas de réponse vous
restez dans une définition relativement
floue de l'exceptionnelle gravité et la
réponse du Sénat a voulu je dirais à
apporter et et mettre en cause en tout
cas préciser cette situation je veux
juste vous dire que il peut arriver
qu'une demandeuse obtienne gain de cause
au motif je vous donne un exemple que la
procréation médicalement assistée par
microinjection intracytoplasque n'est
pas réalisable dans le pays d'origine
vous voyez à quelles aberrations nous
sommes arrivés dans ce dispositif
monsieur le ministre avant que nous
votion bien comme je l'ai dit au Sénat
parce que vous je pense que vous n'avez
pas lu l'intégralité des échanges qu'on
a pu avoir avec les sénateurs ce ce
dispositif est particulièrement conforme
à notre avis à la sage puisque nous
sommes le seul pays avec la Belgique à
avoir cette disposition donc ce serait
étonnant que la CEDH censure des
dispositifs de notre pays qui sont
effectivement dans le droit existe et je
voulais dire d'ailleurs au représentant
du groupe socialiste et group ver Paris
qu'il était membr du gouvernement de
Monsieur Holland que c'était le droit
élaboré également pendant les 5 ans de
présidence de François Hollande donc on
pourrait quand même j'ai parlé des j'ai
parlé des d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et
des partis socialiste j'ai pas parlé de
monde tout le monde non non mais je je
crois que non vous nêtes pas tenu les 5
ans oui je peux d'accord en tout cas les
socialistes ils sont manifestement tenus
les les 5 ans donc non donc c'est c'est
le droit c'est le droit d'un
gouvernement c'est le droit d'un
gouvernement socialiste voilà donc il
apparaît pas totalement inhumain ou
alors vous avez une autocritique assez
forte sur la présidence de Monsieur
Hollande donc il y a la fois une
conformité avec la CEDH et il y a à la
fois je crois la volonté par le
législateur et je pense que vous
pourriez vous en réjouir de monter au
niveau législatif des sujets qui sont
réglementaires d'habitude on demande
plutôt au gouvernement de pouvoir
légiférer sur des mesures qui relèvent
de son pouvoir il vous propose avec le
travail que fait rapporteur général de
le mettre dans la loi c'est plutôt une
garantie ble titre pour chacune et
chacun et peut-être corriger ce
qu'évoque madame louvagi parce que moi
je l'ai constaté moi-même c'est vrai que
ce sont des cas il faut l'avouer très
particulier peu nombreux mais en effet
pas prévu que le titre de séjour
étranger malade puisse être utilisé pour
des PMA sauf si pour des raisons
extrêmement évidentes de la santé de la
personne il y aurait une explication
médical à cela mais on est bien d'accord
que c'est plutôt un abus de ce que
souhaite faire le législateur me
semble-t-il quand il a créé le titre
étranger malade il nous sememble de
notre vision madame la députée que la le
fait de le monter au niveau législatif
permet justement d'éviter
l'interprétation quiévoqué parce que je
crois qu'il y a eu deux jurisprudences
de suite des tribunaux dans le cas que
vous évoquez et il s'appuyit sur le fait
que justement il n a pas de disposition
législative mais qui était de mesure que
réglementaire donc nous pensons à notre
lecture mais je sais que vous avez
travaillé sur cette question et je crois
que c'est la position également de de
l'OFI qu'en le mettant dans le domaine
législatif les tribunaux puisqueon parle
effectivement de gravité pour la santé
ne permettent pas donner des
jurisprudences qui permettent d'accéder
à des traitements comme ceux de la PMA
qui n'ont rien à voir effectivement à la
santé alors sur ces amendements de
suppression je que je vais mettre à vos
voix qui vote
pour les amendements de suppression qui
vote contre ils sont rejetés monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez un amendement
1650 c'est c'est l'amendement dont on
vient de discuter pendant longtemps je
je redis simplement alors d'abord entre
celles et ceux qui me qui me traitent de
criminel monsieur porte celles et ceux
qui me traitent de laxiste je pense
qu'il y a probablement une vérité
peut-être au milieu du chemin peut-être
au milieu du chemin et je réponds à
Madame louvagie que je réponds à Madame
louvagie j'ai j'ai souhaité j'ai
souhaité prendre le Sénat au mot et
vraiment au mot près le Sénat les
rapporteurs en particulier ont indiqué
qu'ils souhaitaent mettre au niveau
législatif la définition contenue dans
l'arrêté et il se trouve que la
définition qu'il met dans le législatif
n'était pas la bonne effectivement au
mot près et donc je reprends ce mot et
j'ai pris le Sénat au jeu et en même
temps je reprendrai les termes de
Monsieur latombe c'est une protection
supplémentaire puisque là nous hissons
au niveau législatif des éléments qui
seront l'objet d'appréciation
quotidienne dans l'évaluation de l'accès
ou pas au titrre étrangers malad
monsieur Lucas mon rapporteur général
vous me faites penser au coyote dans
texavri saz il court derrière une petite
bête et puis à un moment donné il arrive
il tombe de la il tombe de la falaise en
fait vous êtes en train de faire quand
LR vous dit que vous êtes laxiste en
fait à force de courir après la droite
radicalisée et l'extrême droite et et
manifestement sans aucun succès puisque
ni vous ni ministre de l'Intérieur
n'obtenait de majorité sur ce texte les
déclarations dans la presse l'ambiance
ici les déclarations le démontre à force
de courir après eux mais vous emmenez et
et pas seulement vous vous emmenz votre
majorité qui vous suit quasi aveuglément
là au bord du précipice et on bientôt et
on est déjà sur bien des dispositions
tomber dans le précipice il est temps
d'arrêter les frais quand même alors
vous pouvez trouver des formules là vous
avez parlé de notre passé de socialiste
les synthèses molles vous avez
visiblement bien compris ce que c'était
et et l'art de d'écrire des textes qui
ne servent pas à grand-chose si ce n'est
là à vous aligner sur la droite dure
vous avez compris ce que c'était vous
êtes vraiment un digne héritier de
Manuel Vals monsieur de la
porte on écoute alors on peut écouter
monsieur de la porte allez
monsieur de late s'il vous plaît je ne
sais pas si Monsieur Darmanin é un dig
héritier de Monsieur Sarkozi c'est une
hypothèse ou de Monsieur Besson mais il
avait dit au Sénat j'écrirai également
au président de groupe de la Haute
Assemblée Avin de leur présenter les
conséquences selon le gouvernement et
l'office de ce qui est décidé ici
c'est-à-dire l'article 7 monsieur le
ministreavez pas répondu que contenait
ce courrier et quelles sont les
conséquences de selon le gouvernement et
l'OFI ce qui est décidé
ici alors je donne juste la paroleant
après je la parole monsieur ministre
madame jeunevard merci monsieur le
Président donc notre rapporteur général
propose de substituer au mot altération
significative le mot détérioration moi
je trouve que ça n'est pas du tout en
cohérence avec les l'exceptionnelle
gravité euh de la pathologie la
détérioration c'est un terme qui
affaiblit finalement qui va élargir le
dispositif alors même que ce dispositif
mérite d'être recentré madame louvagie
en a montré les excès les aberrations il
faudrait donc le requalifier plus
précisément or vous par ce terme
détérioration vous en élargissez le
spectre ça n'est pas ça n'est pas du
tout
souhaitable monsieur le
ministre dire à Madame jeev qu'on n pas
du tout la même analyse j'ai plutôt
l'impression que l'amendement enfin la
disposition l'amendement du rapporteur
général n'ouvre pas mais permet au
contraire de sécuriser ce qui existe et
qui évite les jurisprudences mais on
aura l'occasion sans doute d'en reparler
compris dans dans l'hémicycle avec
peut-être d'autres arguments mais j'ai
pas du tout la même interprétation que
vous peut-être répondre à Monsieur de la
porte je regrette que le président caner
peut-être la transmission avec
l'Assemblée peut-être se se voilà se
passe mal mais je vais peut-être vous l
le courrier qu'il a donc reçu et comme
reçu tous les présidents de groupe comme
je
étais comme je m'y étais engagé pardon
monsieur le Président mais j'étais
relancé deux fois il me semble que donc
il souhaite le le courer une extinceau
monsieur de la porte le Sénat a adopté
lors de la séance consacrée l' examen du
projet de loi contrôler l'immigration
améliorer l'intégration des dispositions
nouvelles relatives au titre de séjour
étranger qui se prévut de son état de
santé en l'état actuel du droit tout
étranger résidant habituellement en
France dont l'état de santé nécessite
une prise en charge médicale dont le
défaut pourrait entraîner des
conséquences d'une exceptionnelle
gravité et qui ne peut bénéficier
effectivement d'un traitement approprié
dans son pays d'origine se voit délivrer
un titre de séjour pour soins l'OFI est
chargé de rendre un avis sur ces trois
critères les modalités d'appréciation du
critère de gravité de la paologie ne
sont actuellement pas définis dans la
loi mais par un arrêté du 5 janvier 2017
qui fixe les orientations générales
destinées au médecin de l'OFI selon cet
arrêté la gravité se mesure par la mise
en cause d'un pronostic vital madame
jeunevard de l'étranger ou la
détérioration de l'une de ses fonctions
importante l'absence dans le domaine
législatif empêche les tribunaux de
juger favorablement dans les décision
prises par les médecins de l'OFI le
Sénat a donc adopté l'article 1F qui
vise à consacrer au niveau législatif la
définition de ces modalités d'après
assation afin de sécuriser le travail
des agents de l'OFI comme suite à mon
engagement pris au banc de faire au
groupes politiqu des deux assemblées de
mon analyse de sa disposition celle-ci
apparaissent conforme Mons de la porte à
nos obligations constitutionnelles et
conventionnelles la CEDH en particulier
limite très souvent l'application de
l'article 3 de sa propre convention
interdisant les traitements et peines
inhumains et dégradants au cas
d'éloignement d'étrangers malades dont
le pronostique vital est engagé
fortement ou que justifie de
considération humanitaires impérieuses
dans des cas très exceptionnels
de guillemets pour la jurisprudence de
cdH si la Cour ne se limite ne limite
plus sa protection aux étrangers qui
font face au risque imminent de mourir
elle exige à minima que soit prouvé un
risque réel d'être exposé à un déclin
grave rapide et irréversible de l'état
de santé entraînant des souffrances
intenses ou à une réduction
significative de l'espérance de vie
conférer je cite la
CEDH la CEDH conférer à une valeur
juridique plus importante à ces
modalités d'appréciation permettra à
l'administration de disposer d'outil
juridiques renforcés pour limiter les
abus constatés sur les demandes de
bénéfices à ce titre de séjour et
d'ailleurs le courrier cite expressément
expressis verbis madame louvagi la
question de la PMA un titre
d'illustration de ces demande amusive le
dernier rapport de l'OFI s'agissant des
données 2021 indique que depuis 2017 ce
sont 234 demandes qui ont été présenté
par des étrangers qui souhaitent rentrer
en France dans un parcours de
procréation médicalement assisté dans le
même sens ce sont en 2022
45 45 demandes déposées pour des cas
d'obésité non morbide de 218 pour des
motifs liés à l'apnée du sommeil 39 pour
des cas de varis le Sénat a également
adopté l'article 1e qui prévoant en
substance qu'étranger peut bénéficier de
traitement adapté à sa pathologie je
vais pas le faire la lecture inexenstion
mais je terminerai par dire que c'est le
puisqu'on parle de la CEDH si la mise en
œuvre adaptée au cas d'espèce de ces
dispositions par les préfets s'exercera
bien sûr sur le contrôle du jugé
administratif conformément à la
jurisprudence constante du Conseil
d'État de cadh selon le principe d'une
appréciation inconcretto de la situation
des intéressés il importera dès lors
dans la décision prise de porter une
attention particulière au caractère
adéquate et suffisant adéquat des soins
disponibles dans le pays d'origine de
l'étranger les dispositions ainsi votées
par le Sénat siles étaient validé par
l'Assemblée nationale et promulgué par
le Président de la République permettrai
avec la même réglementation montée au
niveau de la loi de pouvoir lutter
contre des jurisprudences qui luttent
qui touchent pardon le contraire de
l'esprit voulu par le législateur dès
2017 donc voilà n'hésitez pas je crois
que c'est c'est
p@.fr bon on va pouvoir voter sur
l'amendement on va pouvoir voter sur
l'amendement du rapporteur sur
l'amendement du rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est adopté sur l'article 1er f
qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté
amendement de suppression de l'article
1er G1 monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur le le président un
très grand nombre d'amendements de
suppression font suite à à celui que je
dépose donc je serai bref nous estimons
que il n'est pas nécessaire il n'est pas
utile d'imposer une caution pour les
étrangers qui voudraient venir étudier
en France la stratégie de la France est
même exactement inverse elle est
méritocratique c'est l'esprit même de la
République et donc nous avons une
stratégie très dynamique de délivrance
de visa étranger en France 11000 l'année
dernière je vous rappelle que c'est la
première cause de migration
contrairement à un certain nombre de
d'affirmations au cours de ces dernières
heures en France 108000 une augmentation
très significative il nous semble tout à
fait néfaste que nous fassions le choix
de privilégier comme le Sénat semble le
souhaiter les enfants qui seraient en
situation aisée à l'étranger nous sommes
pour la méritocratie et c'est le sens de
cette cet amendement de suppression
i j'ai aussi un amendement de
suppression de cette caution
estudiantine qui ne se justifie pas et
qui est orthogonale objectif
d'attractivité de l'université française
madame
buffet madame
châelin merci Monsieur le le Président
je rejoins absolument ce que vous avez
dit ainsi que monsieur le rapporteur
cette cette caution ne se justifie pas
elle va même à l'encontre de de la
mission de l'université qui est euh
d'accueillir tous les élèves qui
souhaitent apprendre et je vous parle de
en tant que député d'une circonscription
où on a un très grand compus
universitaire et c'est une fierté
d'accueillir les étudiants d'où qu'ils
viennent certains viennent de pays aisés
et auraient les moyens de de payer la
caution d'autres viennent de pays plus
pauvres de familles qui ont économiser
pendant des années pour les envoyés en
France qui font leurs études dans des
conditions difficiles souvent dans
parfois au début même sans logement il
loge les Guns chez les autres puis par
le travail par le travail dans leurs
études par le travail à côté de leurs
études ils arrivent à s'en sortir ils
sont déplommés et je pense que c'est une
fierté pour no pays que d'accueillir ses
étudiant madame tourga merci monsieur le
Président bon alors moi je me disais là
on va peut-être enfin enfin parler
d'accueil puisque les étudiants on doit
normalement les les accueillir c'est ce
qu'avait dit Édouard Philippe lors de la
création de bienvenue en France la la
stratégie bienvenue en France il avait
dit face à une concurrence
internationale de plus en plus vive la
France doit rester l'un des acteurs
majeurs de la mondialisation des études
supérieures donc on se disait là ça y
est mais non en fait il est toujours
question d'être suspicieux à l'égard des
étrangers alors soit ils viennent parce
que en fait ils veulent se faire soigner
quittent comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure à avoir un parcours migratoire
terrible tragique et même mourir soit
ils viennent pour faire des études mais
en fait non ils veulent en fait rester
en France après les études alors euh oui
il faut absolument supprimer cet article
et il faut que la France redevienne
attractive comme elle l'a été pendant
des siècles au niveau
intellectuel monsieur
Castellani merci euh président j'iraai
tout à fait dans le même sens euh mettre
en place un dépôt d'une caution
préalable à la délivrance d'un titre de
séjour pour les étudiants étrangers n'a
pas de sens cette mesure est d'ailleurs
contraire toute la méritocratie
française la France souhaite je suppose
que son système universitaire soit
accessible aux étudiants y compris
étranger qui le mérite et qui souhaite
réussir voilà donc c'est l'objet de de
cet amendement merci Madame Caraman
alors oui monsieur le Président et chers
collègues je crois qu'on est là
totalement d'accord pour supprimer ce
cet article parce que je dirais que de
manière très simple les les étudiants
c'est toujours étrangers c'est c'est
toujours une une richesse pour notre
pays n'oublions pas et n'oublions pas
que par à travers leur parcours leurs
études ils deviennent des
ambassadeurs de la Francophonie
également et ça on parle souvent de
francophonie mais quand il s'agit de
mettre des moyens et parler de manière
effective de cela mais on on n passe pas
dans l'acte à l'acte donc du coup je
crois que à travers cette disposition et
à travers l'accueil des étudiants
étrangers on contribu largement et de
manière très concrète sur la
l'attractivité du pays et sur
effectivement la francophonie au-delà
comme des ambassadeur au-delà de la
France Monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président pour
ajouter à ce qu'on dit et très bien dit
mes différents collègues même ceux qui
ont un problème problème pathologique
avec les étrangers et les migrations
devrait aimer les étudiants
internationaux d'ord parce que
l'essentiel d'entre eux aspireent à
repartir dans leur pays d'origine après
avoir fait des études premier air
qu'ensuite il rapportent hein ceux qui
nous disent l'immigration ça coûte cher
1,35 milliards d'euros de bénéfices net
par an pour l'économie française grâce
aux étudiants internationaux euh ça
rapporte voyez là même de votre point de
vue ça devrait être bien ensuite ils
réussissent ils réussissent mieux euh
que les étudiants français là aussi les
études et les chiffres le le démontrent
et enfin si nous sommes ici attachés à
la grandeur de notre pays à son
influence il rayonnent parce que ce sont
des ambassadeurs de la France de euh ses
cultures de son patrimoine de son
économie ensuite à travers le monde et
donc c'est une richesse nous devrions
être unanime pour dire bienvenue en
France aux étudiants internationaux
madame
fossillon euh merci Monsieur le le
président euh on est toujours dans dans
une logique de de suspicion à l'égard
des étudiants extra
communautaires il faut quand même je
crois s'interroger sur le fait
que le le programme bienvenue en France
a ouvert aussi la voix à ce type de de
proposition je suis évidemment
satisfaite que le rapporteur comme le
président de la commission souhaite
supprimer cette
disposition qui aurait été vraiment
préjudiciable pour pour les étudiants
étrangers je pense en particulier aux
mineurs non accompagnés qui ont été pris
en charge par la ze et qui sont parfois
orientés vers des des cartes étudiants
et qui généralement quand même à la
sortie de la ze se retrouve souvent en
grande difficulté en grande précarité et
donc évidemment cette cette caution
aurait affaibli leur chance de de
réussite et
d'émancipation monsieur
Mandon merci monsieur président mais
juste pour dire que le groupe démocrate
se réjouit du dépôt de tous ces
amendements de suppression et que notre
évidemment notre démarche va dans le
même sens et je me contenteraiis de de
dire qu'il est donc défendu
ainsi le suivant n'est pas défendu
monsieur tacher
oui monsieur le Président merci euh oui
très bien la caution estudantinle ne
sera pas votée ce soir mais il faudra
continuer à payer 7000 € par an pour un
étudiant étranger pour pour venir en
France alors qui les paye ces 7000 € par
an par exemple l'étudiant mauritanien
Mauritanie c'est 10 c'est le un pays qui
est classé 159e au rang de l'indice du
développement humain et qui préside le
G5 Sael par exemple étudiant sénégalais
pays cher à votre cœur monsieur le
rapporteur et président du groupe
d'amitié France Sénégal par exemple
étudiant marocains pays avec lequel on a
tant de liens et qui pourtant quand vous
allez au Maroc aujourd'hui les les gens
vous disent j'ai plus de facilité à
envoyer mes enfants étudi aux États-Unis
qu'en France alors effectivement les la
caution studiantin ne sera pas voté ce
soir mais peut-être qu'on pourrait
s'interroger un petit peu de pour savoir
si oui ou non 7000 € par an pour tous
ces étudiants du monde francophone pour
tous ces étudiants des pays avec
lesquels on a tant de liens c'est encore
justifié merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Gouffier Valante oui oui merci
monsieur le Président la mise en place
d'un cautionnement pour la première
délivrance d'une carte de séjour
temporaire étudiant introduite en séance
publique auocéana n'apparaît pas
opportune voire pas du tout opportune
d'une part elle constitue une rupture
d'égalité entre les étudiants d'autre
part elle risque de fragiliser encore
plus les étudiants internationaux qui
subissent aussi le phénomène de
précarité étudiante je rajoute que ce
dispositif fortement désincitatif
s'inscrit à rebours des objectifs
d'attractivité de la France en
particulier sa stratégie bienvenue en
France à destination des étudiants
internationaux et compliquera
l'instruction des dossiers de demande de
titre par nos postes diplomatiques pour
ces raisons notre groupe Renaissance
souhaite la suppression de cet article
monsieur le
rapporteur je le
rapporteur je suis je suis favorable par
définition Miss aux amendements de
suppression en ayant déposé moi-même un
un tout à l'heure je voudrais simplement
signaler pour conclure sur ce sujet sans
doute d'ailleurs notre commission pour
aujourd'hui que la France est le 4e pays
le plus attractif au monde concernant
les étudiants et quel est le premier
pays francophone non anglophone pardon à
être au monde en terme d'attractivité je
pense qu'il faut que nous le restions
nous aurons d'ailleurs le même débat sur
les droits universitaires peut-être
demain monsieur Dumont merci monsieur le
Président les républicains s'opposeront
à ces amendements de suppression parce
que nous pensons qu'en effet ce cette
caution est intéressante et nécessaire
pourquoi parce que la première raison du
séjour en France de délivrance de titre
de séjour chaque année est la raison
étudiante ça fait partie d'une volonté
du gouvernement continue depuis 2017 20
% d'augmentation de titrre entre 2019 et
2022 un/ers des titres de séjour sont
délivrés pour motif étudiant mais il
faut aussi savoir que la première source
immigration illégale en France c'est
l'immigration légale et qui est donc
absolument nécessaire de savoir si
l'étudiant qui est venu et bien reparti
à l'issue et malheureusement la seule
solution pour cela est de mettre en
place ce cautionnement je permets juste
de rajouter une chose c'est que
aujourd'hui la France prend en charge
l'équivalent de 3/4 du coût d'un
étudiant étranger et donc c'est
également nécessaire que nous puissions
être certain que l'étudiant étranger qui
vient vient bien pour étudier et qu'il
est donc nécessaire prochainement de
savoir si on devrait pas suspendre le le
titre de séjour d'un étudiant qui est
multirodoublant ou qui est bloqueur de
fac par exemple madame
Martin donc on a eu droit aux familles
on a droit maintenant on a eu droit aux
familles on a eu droit aux malades et
maintenant on a droit aux étudiants
j'attire votre attention outre sur tous
les arguments qui ont été développés sur
un plan social tout simplement qui
permettent l'accès au savoir et à
l'émancipation sur le fait que l'accueil
d'étudiants étranger en France est un
des facteurs de développement de la
Francophonie alors je sais bien que vous
n'aimez que l'anglais du côté de la
macronie mais il n'empêche qu'il y reste
encore quelques personnes qui sont
attachées à la langue française à sa
finesse et à sa précision et et
accueillir des étudiants étrangers dans
le pays participe évidemment du
rayonnement de la France et de la
Francophonie par ailleurs j'aurais une
question à vous poser selon vous combien
de prix de Nobel combien de prix Nobel
ou de prix Feld ont effectivement étudié
en France pourquoi je dis ça je dis ça
parce que ça serait intéressant de
regarder parce que ça fait partie des
critères du classement de shanghï
classement de shangï donc pour les
universités françaises relativement
auquelles vous êtes souvent en train de
regretter pour ne pas dire chounoter le
le fait que nous n' apparissions pas
dans les 10 premiers
réfléchissez-y qu'organise ce texte de
bout en bout c'est le rétrécissement de
la France le rabougrissement de la
France sur elle-même et en l'occurrence
toutes les universités du monde Ess
d'attirer les étudiants étrangers toutes
toutes sauf nous et qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire en mettant une caution en
plus des frais d'inscription de
bienvenue en France et bien c'est de
faire en sorte de de de réaffirmer le
fait qu'il faille aller vers des
emprunts étudiants vous allez popériser
une population et franchement c'est
scandaleux bon est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut avoir un peu de calme pour la
dernière Inter la soirée madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc la
délivrance d'une carte de séjour
temporaire étudiant constitue le premier
motif de Primo délivrance devant le
regroupement familial avec 87000 titres
délivré en 2021 bon nous au
rassemblement national nous sommes
favorables à l'instauration de cette
caution et je rassure tout le monde elle
sera bien sûr restitué à la sortie de
l'étudiant du territoire national mais
nous devons nous prémunir euh en cas de
dévoiement ou de détournement de cette
filière particulièrement avantageuse que
nous proposons aux Français vous parlez
dans vos amendements de précarité
étudiante mais permettez-moi de vous
dire que la précarité étudiante c'est
vous qui l'organisez si aujourd'hui 56 %
des étudiants ne mangent pas à leur fin
c'est peut-être parce qu'il y a quelques
mois vous avez refusé vous à la macronie
et vous à l'extrême gauche parce que
vous n'étiez pas présent en hémicycle
d'accorder la prolongation du repas à 1
€ donc oui aun nous nous nous voulons
lutter contre la précarité étudiante
nous voulons soutenir d'abord les
étudiants français et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes aussi
favorables au fait de leur réserver la
priorité dans l'accès au logement
étudiant monsieur le Président juste
rassurer madame Rousseau on
supprime on supprime cet article et on
ne vous a pas attendu pour le supprimer
on l' immédiatement déclarer voilà c'est
la position c'est la position de la
majorité
donc bon alors on va passer au vote
voilà qui vote
pour qui vote contre les amendements
sont adoptés suppriment l'article g et
donc je lève la séance de commission
pour ce
soir